EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING TONIGHT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE CURRENT GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO ONE OR TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING. A
TELECONFERENCE ORDERS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUAL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE TWO. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THIS CAN BE SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THE
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND
YOU ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING.
SECURING OUR PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
COURSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE-REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR- OUR HEARINGS
AND THAT'S CLOSE TO THE MATTER
AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE
SOME LACK. TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PATIENTS ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS. AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS WE WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WILL
BE LIMITED TO THREE MINUTES
EACH. ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY DURING PUBLIC COMMENT
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THE NAME AFFILIATION A POSITION
ON THE MEASURES. WE ARE GOING
TO HEAR NINE BILLS TODAY. BUT
SB FIVE ONE FIVE SB SIX THREE
NINE HAVE BEEN RESCHEDULED TO
BE HEARD ON APRIL TWENTIETH. SB
SIX TWO TWO IS ON CONSENT
THEY'RE FULL THEREFORE WE WILL
HEAR SIX BILLS TODAY. AT THE
MOMENT ARE WE WILL- BUT WE
DON'T HAVE QUORUM AND WE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND
START WITH OUR FIRST BILL. OUR
FIRST BILL HUNTER AGENDA AS SB
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN BY CENTER
CORTESE ARE YOU READY TO
PRESENT FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM SURE- THEM IN
SENATORS AND I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN OH SEVEN. SB
CIVIL SOME WILL PROVIDE KERN
FUTURO RESIDENTS OF CONTINUING
CARE RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES
WITH A SENSE OF SECURITY
REGARDING THE SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL COMMITMENT THEY MAKE
IN RETURN FOR LIFELONG HOME
HEALTH CARE. THERE WERE ONE
HUNDRED CONTINUING CARE
RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES ACROSS
TO CALIFORNIA AND THAT NUMBER
IS LIKELY TO GROW TO ADDRESS
THE INCREASED DEMAND FOR HEALTH
AND SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S RAPIDLY GROWING
SENIOR POPULATION. CONTINUING
CARE FACILITIES ARE AN
ATTRACTIVE OPTION FOR SENIORS
SEEKING A LONG TERM LIVING
ARRANGEMENTS. BECAUSE THEY
OFFER VARIOUS LEVELS OF KERR
THAT ADAPT. TO THE NEEDS OF
RESIDENCES H. ALLOWING THEM TO
AGE IN PLACE. ENTRANCE FEES TO
THESE FACILITIES ARE STEEP. THE
AVERAGE DEPOSIT FOR CONTINUING
CARE RETIREMENT COMMUNITY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WAS THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. ON TOP OF
THAT KIND OF HAVE TO HAVE THE
DEPOSIT. RESIDENTS OF COURSE
PAY ONGOING MONTHLY SERVICE
FEES. IN THE THOUSANDS
TYPICALLY. PRESENTS OFTEN SELL
THEIR HOMES SPEND THEIR LIFE
SAVINGS TO ENTER CONTINUE TO
RETURN COMMITTEES BECAUSE THEY
EXPECT. THEY WERE STABLE
HOUSING AND CARE FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THEIR LIFETIMES.
HOWEVER THEY'VE BEEN INSTANCES
WERE CONTINUING CARE PROVIDERS
MISMANAGED HER FINANCES AND
EITHER ALTER THE RESIDENT
AGREEMENTS. TO ADDRESS THEIR
LOSSES OR SHIFT UPON INITIAL
BURDEN ON TO THE RESIDENTS IN
OTHER WAYS. SB SEVEN OH SEVEN
WILL STOP SHOULD TRIGGER SYSTEM
WHICH WILL ALERT THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES AND FACILITIES
AT RISK OF REACHING FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY. IF PROVIDER MEETS
CERTAIN TRIGGERS OUTLINED IN
THE BILL. THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
BE AUTHORIZED TO REQUIRE THE
PROVIDER TO SUBMIT A FINANCIAL
PLAN. A QUARTERLY UPDATES ON
THEIR PROGRESS TO REMEDY THE
FINANCIAL ISSUES. TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY TO RESIDENTS OF
THE BILL STATES THAT PROVIDERS
WHO HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT A FINANCIAL PLAN. BUT
SURE THAT FINANCIAL PLAN ALONG
WITH ANY QUARTERLY REPORTS TO
THE CURRENT RESIDENCE. THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE
FINANCIAL PLANNING QUARTERLY
REPORTS BE SHARED WITH
INDIVIDUALS WHO BECOME A
RESIDENT PRIOR TO THE
REMEDIATION OF EXISTING
FINANCIAL ISSUES. SB SEVEN OH
SEVEN. ONE SURE THE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES AND RESIDENTS
OF CONTINUING CARE RETIREMENT
COMMUNITIES. HAVE THE CRITICAL
INFORMATION THEY NEED. TO
IDENTIFY FINANCIAL DEFICIENCIES
OF A PROVIDER BEFORE IT'S TOO
LATE TO TAKE CORRECTIVE ACTION.
I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT I
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE AND-
WITH A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. LET ME ALSO NOTE THAT
WE HAVE HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY.
OVER THE PHONE LINE. IGNITES
YOU HERNANDEZ- WHO IS A
CONSULTANT TO PREPARE THE
CONSULTANT TO THE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUING CARE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION MARGARET GRIFFIN
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE KERR RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION. AGAIN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
WE WILL NOW OPEN IT UP TO
ASSIST AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION
LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL BE LIMITED TO
THREE MINUTES EACH AND WE'LL GO
AHED AND BEGIN WITH THE
WITNESS NUMBER ONE MISTER
HERNANDEZ. I'M SURE IT'S OKAY
IF WE CAN HAVE A MURDER
CRITICAL FIRST. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON MARGARET GRIFFIN.
PRESIDENT OF NY CALIFORNIA
CONTINUING CARE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION OR CAROL CHRO. ONE
RESIDENT OF UNIVERSITY
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY C. C. R.
C. IN DAVIS. MY HUSBAND AND I
MOVED TO R. C. C. R. C. SIXTEEN
YEARS AGO I'VE BEEN ON THE
CALPERS BOARD SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINE. THE PROGRAM
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN.
CONGRESS THE SOLE ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING SENIORS LIVING IN
CCRCS IN CALIFORNIA. OUR
MISSION IS TO ENHANCE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE COMPARTMENTAL
SECURITY OF CCRC RESIDENTS. AND
WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR SB
SEVEN OH SEVEN. SENATE
CORTESE'S. MENTIONED THE
EIGHTEEN. FOR CCRC RESIDENTS
ARE SUBSTANTIAL AND AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE WE ARE VERY INTERESTED
IN THE FINANCIAL SOLVENCY OF
OUR PROVIDERS. CURRENTLY I HAVE
NO WAY OF KNOWING IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS DETERMINED THAT MY C. C. R.
C. IS ON SHAKY GROUND WHEN IT
COMES TO FINANCIAL SOLVENCY.
NOR DO I KNOW IF THE SS OF THE
MIDDLE WHERE OF SUCH A
SITUATION WHERE IT'S TAKEN ANY
ACTION IN THAT REGARD. SB SO OH
SEVEN ESTABLISH EARLY
INTERVENTION SYSTEMS BASED ON
THE CCRCS CURRENT PERFORMANCE.
TESTING NEEDED TO IDENTIFY
MEDICAID MORE RESOLVE FINANCIAL
ISSUES. SO THAT A PROVIDER MAY
AOID INSOLVENCY AND BANKRUPTCY.
THIS IS WHY SB SEVEN OH SEVEN
IN SELLING TO CCRC REFORMS AND
I WOULD NOTE THAT OUR INDUSTRY
HAS EXPERIENCED THREE
BANKRUPTCIES IN RECENT YEARS. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND WILL
GO BACK TO LEAD WITNESS NUMBER
ONE. YOU'RE NOT INSURED NOW SIR
HERNANDEZ ALSO ON BEHALF OF
CONGRESS LEADERS OF TIME- I AM
JUST AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS FOR.
THANK YOU. AT THIS MOMENT WILL
BE GOING TOWARD LOOKING FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT AND
BEGINNING HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE C. NINE PRO TWENTY
FORTY. C. NINE WILL BEGIN-
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA TELEPHONE.
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN. WE WILL NOW MOVE. TO
THOSE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE OF
THIS AS A REMINDER TO THOSE WHO
ARE WAITING ON THE PHONE PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. MODERATOR PLEASE PUMP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY AND
SB SEVEN ZERO SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AT
THIS TIME IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY. ONE MOMENT WE HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP.
AND THERE'S ONLY
ONE CUED UP I'M I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND OPEN YOUR LINE- ONE
TO SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I THINK THEY TOOK THEMSELVES
OUT OF THE QUEUE. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU M. THANK YOU
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM
OPPOSITION- BUT WHEN THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION TO TESTIFY BUT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY. AT THE MOMENT
SO WE'LL MOVE TO. PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION BEGINNING
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE C.
NINE TWENTY FORTY. SEEN IN
NONE. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN- ALREADY CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINE AND PROVIDE US
WITH A COUNT OF INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY. YES SIR A
BLANK TO SIXTY. ONE MOMENT. I
WILL GO EXCUSE ME WE WERE LYING
TO SEVENTY SEVEN TO START TO
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH
MARKETS REPRESENTING LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA WE ACTUALLY- HAVE A
NEUTRAL POSITION WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THE BILL'S SPONSORS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WHAT ARE DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL-
INDIVIDUALS WAITING. IN THE
QUEUE. IN OPPOSITION ONE MOMENT.
HAVE SOMEBODY. ARE WE WILLING
TO SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BOB SOME REASON THAT LINE IS
NOT QUEUING UP I APOLOGIZE-
THEY TOOK THEMSELVES OUT OF THE
QUEUE IS WHAT HAPPENED IT'S
JUST. DO WE AVE ANY ADDITIONAL
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE CUTE. NOT
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU THANK
YOU MODERATOR- AT THIS MOMENT
AT LIKE TO BRING IT BACK TO
THAT- COMMITTEE AFTER ANY.
CLEMENCE SENATOR PAN. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- CIRCLE T. Z.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD CLEARLY IF A
SENIOR OR SEEN A COUPLE YOU
KNOW BASICALLY TAKE THEIR LIFE
SAVINGS. AND IN EXCHANGE FOR A
PROMISE WE NEED TO BE SURE THAT
THAT PROMISES KEPT AND-
CERTAINLY. OR ONE MIGHT
QUESTIONS IS THAT- WHAT HE SEES
THE ROLE OF THE PARM SOCIAL
SERVICES IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
OVERSEE AND ENSURE THAT
PROMISES CAP SO I UNDERSTAND
THAT IN YOUR BILL FOR EXAMPLE-
THAT THEY DO NEED TO TRY THESE
REPORTS- SO THEY'RE GONNA GET
REPORTS- THEY ALSO TRIED
REPORTS TO PEOPLE WHO I GUESS
ARE INTERESTED IN PURCHASING-
AND ARE ENGAGING IN THIS.
ALTHOUGH I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S FOR EXAMPLE ANY
STANDARDS AVAILABLE SO IF
SOMEONE WANTS TO DO IT DATA
DUMPED THE FINANCIALS ON. A LOT
OF TIMES PEOPLE AREN'T SURE HOW
TO INTERPRET THAT IT'S THERE
SOME ASSISTANCE DSS IS SUPPOSED
TO GIVE TO PEOPLE SOME RATING
SYSTEM LIKE THE- YEAH
FINANCIALLY THEIR GREEN YELLOW
RED ORANGE OR SOMETHING OR-
SERVICES SO TO ENTER PRINT THE
DATA THAT THEY MAY BE GETTING
AND ALSO OF COURSE ONCE YOU
READY MADE THAT PURCHASE AND
YOU'RE A- MADE THAT COMMITMENT.
AND NOW YOU'RE NOT. IN A
FACILITY OR US ARE IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S- GET FINANCIAL
TROUBLE. WHAT KIND OF
ASSISTANCE- SHOULD WE TRY TO
RENDER BECAUSE THEY EVER PUT
THEIR MONEY AND SELF I REALIZE
THIS IS A BIT LARGER IN YOUR
BILL- BUT IF YOU HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS YOU WANT TO SHARE WITH
ME ABOUT WHAT WE USE AND HOW
YOU SEE- THESE THINGS MIGHT BE
ADDRESSED AND- HOW YOUR BILL
SERVED GETS US IN THAT
DIRECTION WHICH I KNOW IT IS A
POSITIVE MOVE AND TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATOR INTO THROUGH THE CHAIR
A RESPOND TO- E. RIGHT THIS
BILL- BY. DID HAS NOT. AT LEAST
AT THIS POINT ATTEMPTED TO TAKE
ON OF THE BROADER ISSUE OF
REMEDIES OR- OR SPECIFIC
REGULATORY PENALTIES FOR
EXAMPLE IT'S REALLY. AT THIS
STAGE. TO TAKE THAT FIRST STEP
WHICH I THINK IS BOTH TECHNICAL
IMPORTANT SAME TIME OF
REQUIRING TRANSPARENCY- SO
THAT. EVEN IN EVEN. EVEN IN IN
THE FREE MARKET SITUATION OF
COPY AT EMPTOR- HE'S YOU LEAST
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY EVEN IF
YOU'RE SHOPPING FOR A FACILITY
LIKE THIS TO GET A HOLD OF
FINANCIALS FOR- A- AN
ORGANIZATION- THAT YOU'RE ABOUT
TO SPEND. YOU KNOW PERHAPS A
THIRD OF A MILLION DOLLARS OF
YOUR LIFE SAVINGS ARE YOUR
FAMILIES- BUT DOLLARS TO GET IN
WE HAVE. HAD SOME DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS OF THAT
YOU ALLUDE TO. OF WHICH I THINK
ARE IMPORTANT I THINK THAT IF
NOT WITH THIS BILL THAT ARE
EVENTUALLY IMPORT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE UP FOR
EXAMPLE. A AND AGAIN NOT TO
COMPLICATE THINGS TODAY ON THIS
BILL BUT- HI THE USE OF THE USE
OF REAL ESTATE LEASE CONTRACTS
AS OPPOSED TO. CONTRACTS THAT
ARE TIED TO THESE KINDS OF
REQUIREMENTS. IS BOTHERSOME TO
ME AND TO OTHERS FOR EXAMPLE.
ON THE ONE HAND- YOU KNOW THE
REMEDIES AS YOU KNOW AS WE ALL
KNOW UNDER THOSE KIND OF
CONTRACTS- VERY PRESCRIPTIVE
AND VERY LIMITED AS OPPOSED TO
SOMEBODY BEING ABLE TO- HINO
TO. A PERHAPS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
A BROADER MENU OF REMEDIES.
THEY WANT TO STAY THERE- MAYBE
THEY WANT TO STAY THERE AND
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
NOT RETALIATED AGAINST FOR
BRINGING UP- ISSUES- OF CONCERN
ABOUT THE VIABILITY THEIR
INVESTMENT SO I DO THINK THAT.
MORE WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE WE
HAVE HAD DISCUSSIONS LIKE THAT
ALONG THE WAY- I DON'T KNOW- IF
THE BEEF WE'LL GET TO THE POINT
OF FURTHER AMENDMENTS TO GET
INTO THAT AREA- BUT WE'RE
CERTAINLY OPEN ALONG THE WAY
TO- YOU KNOW TO TRY TO DELAY.
DEAL WITH SOME MORE OF THE
DETAILS- THAT WILL BE IMPORTANT
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- I THINK IT I'M NOT GOING
TO ASK YOU TO TRY TO PUT ALL
THE REMEDIES INTO THE SIGHTINGS
ABOUT REPORT BUT A BILL FROM
THE MOVING ON TRANSPARENCY-
CERTAINLY ONCE I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL IN THE MOVE
TO BUILT APPROPRIATE TIME- BUT
I DID WANT TO SERVE POLICE
LATER DISCUSSION OPEN WHETHER
IT'S IN THIS BILL IN THE FUTURE
BILL- TO. START YOU KNOW ONCE
WE HAVE THE TRANSPARENCY WE
ALSO NEED TO THEN THINK ABOUT
REMEDIES AND- YEAH WHAT DO YOU
DO FOR A SENIOR SO YOU GOT
SENIORS ARE ENTERING THEY THEY
THEY AT LEAST HAVE SOME MORNING
ONCE YOU'RE IN THERE YOU'RE
VERY COMMITTED THAT MONEY IT'S
NOT THAT YOU HAVE A WHOLE LOT
OF THE MONEY TO GET YOURSELF
BACK OUT AGAIN SO WE'VE WE'VE
GOT THINK ABOUT REMEDIES AS
WELL. BY APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THIS FIRST STEP AT THIS BILL
AND DESK AND I SORT OF MOVED TO
BUILD. THE PROBABLY TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER PANTAS.
COURT TO. ADDED AND TO. ORDERS
WHICH I TO CLOSE AT. TIME THE
APPRECIATE DISCUSS IN THE CAR-
ALL TAKEN SERIOUS IN A SOCIAL
VERY MUCH AGREED TO AND- I
WOULD JUST ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR AT
THISMOMENT WE WILL TAKE- WILL
GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH QUORUM.
BOB TURNED Q. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FOR TARO HERE JONES.
PROTECT CORTESE. THERE ARE SOME
OTHER- PAN THERE. AND WILL ALSO
GO AHEAD AND ADD UP THE CONSENT
ITEMS THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT ITEMS SB
SIX TWO TWO BY RUNOFF HER TADO
YES HI. PORTATO ARE JONES JONES
I CORTES C. CORTEZ THE I. COM
MARKER HI FROM OTHER AYE PAN HI
FAN I. WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
QUORUM AND WE'VE ALSO- THE
CONSENT ITEM- IS. ABOUT. OKAY
SO NOW WE WERE GOING BACK TO.
SENATE BILL SEVEN ZERO SEVEN-
TURN CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL I GUESS TECHNICALLY I
GUESS I SHOULD MAKE THE MOTION
AFTER THE COURTS BEEN
ESTABLISHED ON THIS BILL. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER BENEFIT SHEET THAT. HE
CLOSED. SB SEVEN OH SEVEN THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HURTADO. I'M
TADO I'D JONES. JONES I CORTESE
ALL RIGHT PARTISI I CALLED
LONGER. COM LONGER BY PAN NIGHT
AND I. I DIDN'T YEAH COURTESY.
PUT AND DISCONTENT. OKAY NEXT
UP WE HAVE CENTER TIME DOES
STILL SHE'S GONNA BE PRESENTING
SB SIX OH NINE I THINK FRAZIER
ASKED AND BEFORE BEFORE I
PRESENTED TO STYLE ONE AND- BOB
STATED ON S. SEVEN ZERO SEVEN
THAT BILL IS OUT WITH THE- BOAT
OF. FIVE ZERO THANK YOU AND I'M
TO. BE SIX OR NINE IT'S OKAY
THANK YOU SO GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB SIX ZERO NINE WHICH
ESTABLISHES CAL PRESSION
PLACEMENT AND TRAINING
EXPANSION ND IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM AND I'M HAPPY TO SET
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TODAY
I OFTEN. YEAH I ASK MYSELF. IS
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE HOW WE
CAN IMPROVE THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
OUT THROUGH OUR WORK AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT OUR WORK HERE IS
VERY CRITICAL. NOW MORE THAN
EVER IN THE PAST YEAR OVER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION JOBS HAVE
BEEN LOST AS A RESULT OF THE
COLBERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SOME
ARE PREDICTED THAT MANY OF
THOSE JOBS MAY NOT RETURN FOR
YEARS OF EVER. THE REALITY IS
THAT MANY HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN LEFT BEHIND WHEN IT COMES
TO OPPORTUNITIES. THE LOSS OF
JOBS HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
JOB TRAINING AND RESKILLING
SERVICES THAT WILL PREPARE
IMPACTED WORKERS TO RETURN TO
APPOINTMENTS. AND ACCESS
QUALITY JOBS WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS PROGRAM WILL DO SB
SIX ZERO NINE BUILT UPON AN
ALREADY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM BY
REQUIRING THE STATE TO SEEK OUT
CONTRACTS THAT PROVIDE INTO
SERVICES THAT ARE REFLECTIVE OF
REGIONAL WORKFORCE NEEDS. AND
FOCUS ON SERVICE. SPECIFIED
POPULATIONS INCLUDING
INDIVIDUALS FOR TRIBAL MEMBERS
MIGRANT AND SEASONAL
FARMWORKERS AND YOUTH WHO ARE
IN OR HAVE AGED OUT OF THE
FOSTER CAR SYSTEM. IN ADDITION
TO THE EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING
OFFERED UNDER THIS PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS CAN RECEIVE
PAYMENTS FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PROGRAM PARTICIPATION
LIKE TRANSPORTATION. AND CHILD
CARE. ANOTHER IMPORTANT
ATTRACTIVE FEATURE OF T. AND T.
IS THE AVAILABILITY OF FEDERAL
FUNDS TO PAY FOR PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION AND OPERATION.
OF CALFRESH IAN T. STATES CAN
ALSO OBTAIN 50% FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR PROGRAM COST
THIS MEANS THAT EVERY NON
FEDERAL DOLLARS SPENT ON ENT
CAN GENERATE A DOLLAR FIFTY ENT
SERVICES. IN ADDITION TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS OR ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE ENT SERVICES ARE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE A 75%
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT. IN THIS
CASE THE STATE WOULD GET A
DOLLAR SEVENTY FIVE AN EMT
SERVICES FOR EACH NON FEDERAL
DOLLARS SPENT. SB SIX ZERO NINE
ALSO RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE
OF ADULT EDUCATION AND CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION BY
REQUIRING THE STATE AS
PERMITTED BY FEDERAL LAW TO
DECKS DESIGNATE AND ROME AND
THESE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS. AS
MEDIAN STUDENT EXEMPTION FROM
SNAP WORK REQUIREMENTS. AS
UNEMPLOYMENT AS UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES SOAR AND THE NEED FOR
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
INCREASES IT IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER THAT THE STATE MAKE INVESTMENTS THAT PREPARE
ITS WORKFORCE TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF LOCAL EMPLOYERS. PLUS THIS
PROGRAM ALSO PROVIDES FEDERAL
TAX INCENTIVES TO EMPLOYERS
THAT HIRE ENT RECIPIENTS. THE
CALPERS ENT EXPANSION AND
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM WILL DO
JUST THAT. I'M HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT I HAVE. THERESA
BOOZE MAN WITH THE COMMUNITY
ACTION PARTNERSHIP OF TULARE
COUNTY. YES ALL RIGHT THE
MODERATOR IF WE CAN NOW BRING
ON TREES EGGMAN PLEASE. ONE
MOMENT. GOOD MANAGER LINE OPEN
YEAH IT IS OKAY GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY MY
NAME IS THERESA WAS MINE AND I
AM THE DIVISION DIRECTOR FOR
COMMUNITY SERVICES EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING ALSO KNOWN AS HE SAID
HE SAID OF THE COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCY LOCATED IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING
THE WAR ON POVERTY SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX MOST
RECENTLY WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
THROUGH OUR CALFRESH INTO
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE LOCAL
CALFRESH RECIPIENTS VIABLE
OPPORTUNITIES WE UNDERSTAND
THAT NOT EVERYBODY IS THE SAME
THAT IS WHY WE OFFER A VARIETY
OF PATHWAYS TO SELF
SUFFICIENCY. SOME READINESS
PREPARATION AND I'M JOB
SEARCHING ASSISTANCE SINCE ARE
OFFERED THROUGH OUR LOCAL
CONSERVE IT EXCUSE ME THROUGH
OUR ONE STOPS THIS HAS BEEN A
VERY BENEFICIAL- SERVICE
ESPECIALLY DURING MY THAT
PANDEMIC MANY PEOPLE HAVE
GOTTEN AFFECTED AND LOST JOBS
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN WORKING HOWEVER THIS HAS
REALLY GIVEN THEM A PATHWAY TO
FIND OPPORTUNITIES IN OTHER
AREAS WHEN THEY'RE THERE
EMPLOYMENT HAVE CLOSED DOWN.
ALSO DURING LOCAL CONSERVATION
CORPS WHO WERE ABLE TO OFFER
HANDS ON TRAINING TO AG-
INDIVIDUALS AGES EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE BY OFFERING HOT
HANDS ON TRAINING AND IN THE
TRADES AS WELL AS CONSERVATION
WORK PROJECTS. AND WHILE THEY
ALSO CAN WORK WHILE WHILE
EARNING A HIGH. SCHOOL DIPLOMA
AT THE SAME TIME. AND ALLOW FOR
INTO. THAT ME VERY. OPERATE TO
COME INTO THE PROGRAM WANTED
ONE GREATER OF THIS. IS A YOUNG
LADY BY THE NAME OF PORTANTINO-
SHE WEARS IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM HER MOTHER DIED AT THE
AGE OF FOUR. UPON GRADUATION
SHE HAD NO WORK EXPERIENCE BUT
THROUGH THE CON. BEING REFERRED
BY HER AND SOCIAL WORKER IT WAS
REFERRED TO OUR LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS BUT SHE WAS
ABLE TO GET HANDS ON TRAINING.
IN AND PROVIDING OUT YOUNG
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY
WITH A RECYCLING PRESENTATIONS
AND CONSERVATION PRESENTATIONS-
AND AFTER THAT SHE WAS ABLE TO
GAIN FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT. AND
ROLLED INTO OUR HIGH SCHOOL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THIS ALLOWED
HER TO BECOME SELF SUFFICIENT
AND HAVE A PATHWAY- TOWARDS- A
HIGHER EDUCATION. ADDITIONALLY
WE ALSO PROVIDE SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT DON'T MEET THE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
CRITERIA WITH HANDS ON TRAINING
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN IN THE WORK FORCE OF FOR A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME. AND
TRANSITIONING. THEM INTO A
TRAINING. READ WORK EXPERIENCE
HELLO OF THEM GAIN THAT
VALUABLE EXPERIENCE IT'S GOING
TO BE NEEDED FOR THEM WHEN THE
ENGINE THE WORLD OF WORK. WE
ALSO AS PART THE- WE OFFER.
SERVICES THIS ALLOWS US TO
CONTINUE THE COMMUNICATION WITH
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
RECEIVED BOTH OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO SUSTAIN THAT FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT- THROUGHPUT. SB SIX
OH NINE AGENCIES SUCH AS OURS
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THIS
CONTINUED SERVICE NEEDED WITHIN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS. TIME THAT SO MANY HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED BY THE COVENT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU MS GOODMAN- I
THINK THAT WAS IT FOR LEAD
WITNESSES- SO WE WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
WHICH I DON'T SEE ANY. IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TWO AT NO
WITNESSES THERE- MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINE WE KEEP WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF SB SIX OH
NINE. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF S. B. O. R.
ONE OH NINE PLEASE PRESS STAR.
R. ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO THANK
YOU MISTER MODERATES SB SIX OH
NINE. I APOLOGIZE I MISSED MIS
HEARD YOU COME FROM. SB SIX OH
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND WE HAVE ONE I
QUEUED UP AND THAT'S FROM ONE
TO EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALEX WILL GO. TO ONE TO EIGHTY
FIVE. HI THIS IS JEN FROM ANY
OF W. CALLING. SB SIX ALIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE'LL TRY
TO RE OPEN TO EIGHTY THREE I
THINK THEY TOOK THEMSELVES OUT
TO KILL. OKAY MISTER MURRAY IF
YOU COULD JUST CHECK ONE MORE
TIME FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX OR NINE MAKE SURE WE
GOT EVERYBODY. THANK YOU ONCE
AGAINST PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
FOR SUPPORT ON. SIX OH ONE SIX
OH NINE. AND WE HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT. THEY
SHOULD BE WITH US ONE SECOND
THERE WITH THE OPERATOR. SORRY
ABOUT THE DELAY THERE TO
GETTING THEIR LINE NUMBER ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. FOR ANYBODY ELSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. I'M
GONNA BE HERE ALL DAY AND
FISHING REYES I FOUND IT AND WE
WILL GO TO NINE TWO EIGHTY SIX
IN SUPPORT. GOING TO EIGHTY SIX
YOU ARE OPEN. WELL ARE FOR SB.
THREE FIVE FOUR. WE ARE NOT ON
THAT THE- OKAY BRING ALONG IF
ANYBODY WANTS TO SPEAK ON S. B.
ONE. NOBODY ELSE IS IN Q. SIX
OH NINE. ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF
ONE B. SIX OH NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP HERE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FOR THE
CALLER THAT WAS CALLING ON SB
THREE FIFTY FOUR THAT'LL BE
LATER IN THE- COMMITTEE HEARING
SO STAND BY. HE SAYS I CANNOT.
THE RESERVE SOMEBODY COMING UP
MISTER MODERATOR. DESCRIBED
STABLE OKAY WHAT YOU'RE GIVING
UP WE'RE DONE WITH THE-
TESTIMONY IN FAVOR OF SB SIX OH
NINE I UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO
LEAD WITNESS ON OF OPPOSITION
SO WE'LL GO TO THE- INSIDE THE
CAPITOL IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
WE HAVE NOBODY WAITING TO SPEAK
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN NOBODY
WAITING TO SPEAK MISTER
MODERATORS ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION. TO
SB. SIX OH NINE. AND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX OH NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE ZERO. ONE MOMENT ONE
IS WITH AN OPERATOR. EVERYBODY
ELSE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. DID YOU SAY THERE IS
ONE COMING UP. YES SIR THERE
WITH THE OPERATOR. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWO NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWENTY TWO NINETY YOU ARE OPEN.
ONE TO NINETY. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SPEAK LINE TO NINETY. HI
THERE. THEY ARE NOT RESPONDING
OKAY THANK YOU MR MODERATOR OF
ANYBODY ON THE CALL IS CALLING
IN FOR OTHER BILLS AND THEY
WILL COME UP- IN ORDER- SO WE
WILL CLOSE THE TESTIMONY-
PUBLIC TESTIMONY ON SB SIX OH
NINE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. OF
THE BILL THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION- CENTER TARA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK AYE
DISRESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I
ABOUT. THAT ALL RIGHT WE CAN
TAKE THE ROLE. SB SIX OH NINE
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO I
FURTADO I'D JONES HI. JONES I
CORTES C. LIKE CORTEZ THE BUY
COM LONGER. KAMLAGER I PAN AND
I. THAT BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO AND
WE WILL TURN THE DIETS BACK TO
THE CHAIR. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL BE
MOVING ON TO SB TWO FOUR SIX
AGENDA ITEM FOR AND WE HAVE
SENATOR LEYVA HERE READY TO
PRESENT. AND SET A LIMIT FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM VERY EXCITED TO BE
HERE TO PRESENT SB TWO FORTY
SIX THE CHILD CARE
STABILIZATION FORMULA.THIS
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A SINGLE
REGIONAL LIES REIMBURSEMENT
RATE SYSTEM FOR CHILD CARE
PRESCHOOL AND EARLY LEARNING
SERVICES CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
HAS A MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM
THAT PROVIDES THESE IMPORTANT
SERVICES TO OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS. SPECIFICALLY HAS TWO
SEPARATE ONLINE SYSTEMS FOR
REIMBURSING PROVIDERS THAT MEET
TO DIFFERENT STANDARDS THE
EXISTING BIFURCATED SYSTEM RATE
RATE SYSTEM AND INADEQUATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES COMPLICATE
EFFORTS TO FUND AND DELIVER
HIGH QUALITY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS THAT MEET
THE DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS OF ALL
CHILDREN. WHILE ALSO ADDRESSING
THE HEALTH SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF CHILDREN BEING SERVED
THIS ADELINE TO SYSTEM APPROACH
LIMITS X. ACCESS FAIL TO
MAXIMIZE PROGRAM QUALITY AND IS
FORCING MANY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS OUT OF BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS CREATED BY THE CURRENT
RATE SYSTEM RESOURCE
EXPENDITURE SHOULD BE
STREAMLINED AND EXPANDED IN A
WAY THAT ONE COMPENSATES
TEACHERS AND PROGRAMS FOR THE
COSTS OF PROVIDING CARE. TO A
RESPONSIVE TO THE REBEKAH NAMIK
DELIVERY AND DIVERSITY. OF
MEANING VARYING QUALITY
STANDARDS AND FOR INCENTIVIZES
HIGH STANDARDS AND
PARTICIPATION IN RESEARCH BASED
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS. IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN JUST ONE
AND NINE CHILDREN. ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIZED CARE IN CALIFORNIA
RECEIVE SERVICES HOWEVER THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
TREMENDOUSLY INCREASED THE NEED
FOR CHILD CARE AS WE SAW
PROVIDERS SHUT THEIR DOORS AND
THOSE THAT REMAINED OPEN OR
FINANCIALLY SQUEEZED TO THE
LIMIT. NOW MORE THAN EVER IT IS
TIME TO RESTRUCTURE HOW WE
REIMBURSE PROVIDERS TO ALLOW
THEM TO KEEP THE DOORS OPEN AND
SERVE MORE CHILDREN AFTER ALL
WITHOUT CHILD CARE THERE REALLY
IS NO ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
THROUGH THESE REFORMS
CALIFORNIA CAN ACHIEVE A MORE
EQUITABLE SYSTEM TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
MAXIMIZE PUBLIC BENEFIT. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO MENTION THAT
THIS BILL WILL E AMENDED IN
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IF AND WHEN IT PASSES
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE. TO
REFLECT AT THE BASE INTRUM RATE
SHOULD BE THE EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE UP TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN R. M. R. WHICH IS THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE. THIS
AMENDMENT IS IN LINE WITH CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED
BARGAINING EFFORTS. I WOULD NOW
LIKE TO INTRODUCE TO US NURTURE
WITH CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER
AND ALEX TO CAPRI WITH FIRST
FIVE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOT OPEN IT UP TO AN
ASSISTANT SUPPORT OPPOSITION
LEADER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL BE LIMITED TO
THREE MINUTES EACH AND WILL
BEGIN WITH A WITNESS NUMBER ONE.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THIS IS YOUR LINER IS OPEN
PLEASE ON YOU. HELLO HI WE
CAN'T HEAR YOU. HELLO PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. DO WE
HAVE LEAD WITNESS NUMBER ONE
DONNY'S A SNEER AND DONNA HI
DONNA DONNER INTERFERE. PLEASE
BEGIN WITH WE CAN HEAR YOU. HI
THIS IS DONNA IS THERE MY NAME
IS DONNA SNARE INJURE AND I'M
HAPPY TO BE HERE TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE S. B. TWO FOUR
SIX WE'VE BEEN SO THRILLED TO
WORK WITH SENATOR LEYVA ON THIS
LEGISLATION- OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER AND
CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF LOS
ANGELES. ARE PLEASED TO BE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AS
SENATOR LEYVA MENTIONED
CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY LONG
HISTORY OF FUNDING SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE BUT BECAUSE OF THAT
HAS A BIFURCATED SYSTEM OF
REIMBURSEMENT AND THAT THE
SYSTEM CURRENTLY FUNDS THROUGH
A STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE
WHICH IS THE DAILY RATE THAT IS
THE SAME ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
AND NOT TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE
DIFFERENCES IN DOING BUSINESS.
AND REGIONAL MARKET RATE WHICH
IS REQUIRED TO BE CONDUCTED
EVERY TWO YEARS BY OUR FEDERAL
FUNDING WE WORKED UP FOR A LONG
TIME OVER TEN YEARS ON. REFORM
PROPOSALS AND- A WORK GROUP-
WITH CAN BE IN A FEW YEARS AGO
THAT PUT TOGETHER A WHITE PAPER
WHICH IS THE FOUNDATION BILL
AND IT IT HAD INCLUDED HUNDREDS
OF STAKEHOLDERS FROM THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THE BILL HAS WIDE
SUPPORT- WE DID SOME WORK- THE
PRIOR BILL SB ONE SEVENTY FOUR
LAST YEAR IT WAS- MODIFIED TO
BECOME ALIGNED WITH THE MASTER
PLAN FOR EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE WHICH WAS RELEASED THIS
YEAR. AND WE ARE VERY PLEASED
TO BE ABLE TO BRING THIS BILL
BACK BEFORE COMMITTEE AND I'M
HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU- WE
WILL NOW BE MOVING ON TO THE
WITNESS NUMBER. TWO GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALEX TO
CAPREOL AND THE LEGISLATIVE
COORDINATOR AT FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE THRILLED
TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF SB TWO
FORTY SIX. MY COLLEAGUE DIDN'T
EXCELLENT JOB OF EXPLAINING HOW
WE GOT HERE AND THE HISTORY
LEADING UP TO THE INTRODUCTION
OF THE DELL I'LL FOCUS MY
COMMENTS ON THE VARIOUS
COMPONENTS ABOUT SH SB TWO
FORTY SIX EXPAND ON THE WORK MY
COLLEAGUES HIGHLIGHTED BY
ADOPTING AND ALIGNING WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE MASTER
PLAN FOR EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORRY-
FORM. NAMELY SB TWO FORTY SIX
WE UTILIZED THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REGIONAL MARKET RATE SURVEY AT
THE INTERIM BASE RATE. FOR ALL
PROVIDERS. EL PASO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SERVICES THEY DID.
OF AN BASE STRAIT AS WELL AS AN
ANTI COST OF LIVING AND- FOR
ALL PURPOSE. I DO. SB FORTY
WOULD PROVIDE A- TO YOUR RATE.
MEANING THAT ALL PROVIDERS MEET
THE- STANDARDS. ARE ELIGIBLE TO
READ ADDITIONAL. FINALLY THE
BILL ADOPTED CRISIS RATE
ADJUSTMENT FACTOR. AT JUST THE
NEW NORMAL WE KNOW THAT MORE
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS AND AMAX
WILDFIRES OR OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS. UNFORTUNATELY ENERGY
AFTER. THIS CRISIS RATE FACTOR
WOULD BE TRIGGERED BY A
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY AND
WILL PROVIDE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS OF THE DICTIONARY. TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE THE
SITUATION. LAST HE MAY NEED.
CARE LIAM. EXPENSE DURING EIGHT
THE MERGING. THE CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE ABLE TO USE THE
MALLARD TO TAKE A CRISIS RIGHT
ACTOR. ALL UP THERE HAPPY AND
QUESTIONS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I. ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PUT COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FORCE. HERE ROOM FOR TWO ZERO
THREE. THE NINE ON TO TWENTY
FOUR. TíNH NONE OF. WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN IT UP INDIVIDUALLY
MODERATOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT ON BILL SB TWO FORTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE WILL START
OUT WELL IT'S LINE TO SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. REALLY
ROSENBERGER WITH SK YOU
CALIFORNIA AND YOU W. ON BEHALF
OF THE C. P. U. WE ARE IN
COMPORT WITH THE PENDING
AMENDMENT TO INCREASE THAT-
REACH 85% THANK YOUNG. THANK
THANK. EXCUSE ME AND- WE WILL
NOW GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MARTHA
GUERRERO- REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE ARE SUPPORT AND-
DRIVE OUT THANK YOU. ANNEX
WE'LL GO TO LINE. TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA
CALLING ON ON BEHALF OF COUNCIL
FOR A STRONG AMERICA READY
NATION FIGHT CRIME INVESTING
KIDS AND MISSION READINESS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. BUILDING ALONG
WILL THE LINE TO FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. VALERIE DID
NOW REPRESENTING EVERY HOUSE
CALIFORNIA AND WE AREN'T THE
COURTS SB TWO FORTY SIX THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWO FORTY OR EXCUSE ME
TWO SEVENTY FOUR. HI THIS
CALLING HI THERE I'M OF THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT ATHLETES. TWO FOUR
SIX. SIX WE WOULD LIKE. TO
NINETY THREE. WHAT I FEEL ABOUT
IT ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
INSTITUTE IN LOS ANGELES STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ADELINE TO FOUR TO NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
KELLY REYNOLDS ON BEHALF OF
EARLY EDGE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
SDG. FORTY SIX. THANK YOU AND-
I'M SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR-
AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO FOUR SIX AND WE DO HAVE
NO WITNESSES TO TESTIFY ON.
MOVING ON TO ROOM FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE. THE NON ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. C. NONE ARE MOVING ON TO
THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE A MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES INDIVIDUALLY FOR
THOSE WHAT- WANTING TO- STATE
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO FOUR SIX.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO- YOUR
OPPOSITION FOR LINE S. R. FOR
BILL SB TWO FORTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO
THANK YOU. I AM AT YOUR MIND OR
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB. TWO FORTY
SIX. NOBODY IS CURING QUEUING
UP I'M SURE OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH MODERATOR DAHLE BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT WOULD
ANYBODY LIKE TO COMMENT. THE
BILL. OKAY THANK YOU- AND-
SENATOR LABOR WHICH I'D LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BOB
PAN AND A SECOND TURKEY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON SB TWO FOUR
SIX SB TWO FOUR SIX THE MOTION
IS DO YOU PASS BUT FIRST BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO I AM.
FOR TADO I'D JONES JONES I
CORTESE. COURTESY I'D LOG. PAN
CAN I. OKAY WE WILL BE A WHOLE
OUR THE VOTE OPENED ON THAT
BILL AND FOR EXAMPLE THE YOU
MADAM CHAIR THING YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SOME ON.
WE ARE- IS
LIVE WAITING FOR A COUPLE OF
AUTHORS TO COME AND PRESENT SO
WE'LL JUST WAIT A COUPLE OF
MINUTES. YES. YES OKAY IF WILL
BE NOT SIX AGENDA NUMBER FIVE
SENATE BILL FIFTY BY SENATE
ALONE HELLO KITTY OLD YOUR
QUIET GLAD TO HEAR YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AS I WORKING MOTHER WITHIN I
KNOW THAT CHALLENGING IT IS FOR
CONSTITUENTS THAT TO FIND
HEALTH CARE OPTIONS CURRENTLY
OUR SYSTEM IS ONLY SERVING 10%
OF ELIGIBLE AND DENSE AND
TODDLERS THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
NEED FOR INFANT AND TODDLER
CARE AND SB FIFTY WILL ADDRESS
DEFICIENCIES IN THE SYSTEM TO
BETTER SERVE CHILDREN. LEASING
AND PROVIDER THIS BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE PROVIDERS TO MAKE ANY
CHANGES ALLOWS CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AND PARENTS MORE
FLEXIBILITY. FIRST THIS BILL
WILL OPEN AT THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN
AGES ZERO ONE FIVE. BY OPENING
UP THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
TO MORE AGES BE CONSERVE OUR
UNDERSERVED INFANTS AND
TODDLERS AND ALLOWS FOR
WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN AND T. K. AND K. THIS
BILL ALSO ALLOWS FOR PROVIDERS
TO TRANSFER BETWEEN STATE
PRESCHOOL AND CHILD CARE
CONTRACT. GIVEN PROVIDERS
GIVING PROVIDERS MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO SERVE THE NEEDS
OF THE COMMUNITIES AND TO
ENSURE THE CHILDREN DO NOT LOSE
CARE BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
BIRTHDAY. SB FIFTY WILL ENABLE
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
JESTER BUT YOUNG CHILDREN IN
THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
FINALLY THIS BILL WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR FAMILIES TO ENROLL
AND STAY ENROLLED IN CHILD CARE
IT EASES THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN ON PARENTS AND PROVIDE.
ITS STEP IN PROVIDES THIS BY
ESTABLISHING TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
OF CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY AND
ALLOWING FOR CATEGORICAL
ELIGIBILITY. I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY ATTY LSF AN EARLY AGE
CALIFORNIA AND MICHELLE SAID
WELL- PREVENTS D. FROM IT
CONTAINED- TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR LIMóN WILL I'LL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO WITNESS
NUMBER ONE AND JUST A REMINDER
THAT WE ARE LIMITING- SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO THREE MINUTES
EACH THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE LEAD
WITNESS NUMBER ONE PATTY ON THE
CALL. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN PLEASE PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS PATTY HERRERA REPRESENTING
EARLY I'D CALIFORNIA THE
STATEWIDE NONPROFIT ADVOCACY
GROUP DEDICATED TO IMPROVING
CALIFORNIA'S SYSTEM OF EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE FOR OUR
YOUNGEST RESIDENTS. EARLY I
JUST PROUD TO CO SPONSOR SB
FIFTY WHICH WE SEE IS THE
CRITICAL NEVER TOOK ANY CHILD
CARE SERVICES TO MILLIONS OF
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN THE QUALIFY
FOR PUBLICLY FUNDED PROGRAMS
BUT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO ONE. I
SENATE ALONE HAS HIGHLIGHTED SB
FIFTY WOULD PROVIDE A BASKET OF
POLICY IMPROVEMENTS THAT
TOGETHER WILL STRENGTHEN AND
EXPAND CALIFORNIA'S SYSTEM OF
CARE PARTICULARLY FOR INFANTS
AND TODDLERS AND THREE YEAR OLD
AND POVERTY WHEN THE NEED. IS
MOST ACUTE. OKAY SEVERAL IN.
POSITIONS THAT WILL MAKE IT
EASIER FOR CHILD PROVIDER
CHESTER FAMILY AND CHILDREN.
SUCH AS USING A FAMILY ELIGIBLE
FOR ONE TAX SO PROGRAMS AS
ELIGIBLE FOR CHILD CARE
SERVICES. OKAY SUCH AS THESE
CAN CHANGE OUR LIVES MILLIONS
OF CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
EASING THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN OF THE PROVIDERS TO
THEIR FAMILY. EACH YEAR CHILD
CARE AND GOAL PRETTY DEEP
CRITICAL PER. RETURN HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
CONTRACT FUND BECAUSE OUR
POLICIES AND GOALS FOR THE NEXT
PREVENT THEM FROM OPTIMIZING
THEIR RESOURCES. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FOR EXAMPLE
ACROSS ALL PUBLICLY FUNDED
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE. PROVIDERS RETURNED OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE STATE. WHEN WE
COUPLE THIS DATA WITH A
SIGNIFICANT UNMET NEED FOR
CHILDCARE SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA IT TELLS US THAT
SOMETHING IN. OUR SYSTEM IS
BROKEN. SB FIFTY SIX RECTIFY OF
THESE THAT PRETTY BAD DOLLAR
BUT LET. APPROVED EVERY YEAR
DISTURB THE HEAP LOOKS ON.
NORMAL FAMILY FROM BEING USED
TO THEIR FULL SIX. BY
STREAMLINE PRO QUITE. AND
PROCESS THE AND GRANTED CARE
INCREASE PROVIDER. GREATER
FOCUS TO THAT FIGHT TO MEET THE
NEEDS AND THAT. FINAL WE ARE.
THE STOCKS AND- HI THAT SB DOES
DIMINISH OR TO. THE EXIT
PROGRAM RESOURCE. FORCED IN
ORDER THAT MANDATE PROVIDE TO
CHANGE WITH DOING RIGHT NOW
MISTER FAMILIES. THAT. ASSEMBLY
ABILITIES IN SB FIFTY ARE
SIMPLE KERN THIS SURELY ED
LEAST AT THE TECHNOCRAT STEP
TOWARD ENSURING THAT CAN. NEEDS
NEEDS OF AND FAMILY OUR STATE
AND FOR THIS WE ARE I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MOVING TO WOULDN'T
NUMBER. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOUR
HELLO. HELLO THIS IS MICHELLE
STILL BERMAN P. OF TODAY IN WE
ARE PROUD TO BECAUSE AT FIFTY
OF THE LARGEST CHILD CARE
PRESCHOOL IN THE BAY AREA WE
PROVIDE DOUBTS OF JOB
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN LOAN PAN.
WITH EARLY LAW AND CARE TO HELP
AND WERE TAMPA. SB FIFTY WOULD
STRENGTHEN THE ZERO EAST SAYS
AND IN PROVIDE LIKE A TO BETTER
SERVE THE OF OUR AND FAMILY
ESPECIALLY IN AND TODDLERS
WHICH IS THE GREAT NEED UNMET
NEED IN. WE KNOW THAT CHAO CARE
DURING THOSE EARLY YEARS OF
BRING ABOUT TRANSACTION COUNTY
BURKE LEARN AT THE. SB WOULD
OPEN UP SECRET PROGRAM TO SERVE
CHILDREN TO FIVE. RATHER THAN
ONLY. THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLD.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO BE. MY
STAY CHILD CONTRA THAT SORT
DIFFERENT AGES. AND THE AMOUNT
OF WE HAVE ANY COUNTRY DOES
ALWAYS MEAN THE NEEDS. OF OUR
FAMILY. SB FIFTY WILL PROVIDE
US WITH THE FLEXIBILITY TO
SERVE YOUNGER CHILDREN AND
SHIFT MONEY BETWEEN THOSE
CONTRACTS. SB FIFTY ALSO ALLOWS
PROVIDERS TO BE REIMBURSED
BASED ON CHILD INVOLVEMENT
RATHER THAN ATTEND THAT. WOULD
PROVIDE MORE STABILITY AND
ENABLES PROVIDERS TO FULLY
UTILIZE CONTRACT FUNDS TO SERVE
MORE CHILDREN. RATHER THAN
RETURNING NOT FUNDING TO THE
STATE. AS FIFTY ALSO. FAMILY
CHILD PROVIDER SISTER CHILDREN
IN THE DECREASE PRO. WHICH IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
MORE CHOICES TO PARENTS AND
MORE STABILITY FOR FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDER. GETTING OPERATES
A FAMILY CHILD CARE NETWORK BUT
WE PARTNER WITH FAMILY
CHILDCARE EDUCATORS TO PROVIDE.
EDUCATORS WE PROVIDE FUNDED
CHILD CARE SLOTS. WITH THE
MOMENT AND WORKSHOPS AND
NETWORKING OPPORTUNITIES AND
THE FAMILY CHILDCARE EDUCATORS
PROVIDE NURTURING CARE AND
EARLY LEARNING. THAT IS A QUOTE
FOR ONE OF OUR- MURCIELAGO MAY.
IT INCLUDES CHILD CARE NOW HAS
ME AN EARLY AND. WITHOUT
GETTING- I WOULDN'T AS MANY
CHILDREN IN IN MY CARE. I
WOULDN'T HAVE HAD THE SAME
ABILITY. AT FIFTY WOULD IN A US
USE OUR STATE PRESCHOOL TO
EXPAND OUR FAMILY CARE NOT TO
SERVE TO. AND PARTNER WITH MORE
PROVIDE. IN THE BILL WOULD
ALLOW THE CREATION OF MORE
NETWORKS LIKE CARS ACROSS THE
STATE. SB FIFTY AXIMUM EASIER
FOR FAMILY AND GLIDER I
REDUCING BURDENSOME. THAT
FAMILY COMES TO US AND ARE
ALREADY ENROLLED IN MEDICARE
I'LL CAL FRESHER WITH. WE COULD
AUTOMATICALLY ENROLL THEM
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE WITHOUT
NEEDING TO VERIFY ALL OF THEIR
INCOME INFORMATION. AND PARENTS
WAS VERY ABLE SCHEDULED WOULD
BE SO TO. SUBMITTING A
PAPERWORK. SB FIVE MOVES
TOWARDS A MORE EQUITABLE SYSTEM
LOAN WORKING CAN GET TWENTY
MONTHS ELIGIBILITY FOR CASH
CARE THEY CAN WORK AND CAN
CHILDREN CAN LEARN. FOR ALL
THESE REASONS I- URGE YOU TO
FOR US FIFTY THANK. THANK YOU-
WILL NOT BE MOVING- FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY-
BEGINNING IN ROOM FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE SEEN NONE. OF ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. WE HAVE NO ONE
THERE AND MOVING ON TO THE
TELEPHONE LINES CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINE INDIVIDUALLY
MODERATOR. YEAH FOR THOSE
WAITING. TO IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY. THANK YOU AND ANYBODY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO. SPEAK ON SB
FIFTY PLEASE AND IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
PERSONALLY OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT WILL GOING TO EIGHTY
SEVEN IN SUPPORT. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON DONNA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF COUNCIL FOR A STRONG
AMERICA READY NATION MISSION
READINESS AND FIGHT CRIME
INVESTING KIDS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT RULING TO FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BALLERINA
NOW WITH EVERY CHILD AND WE ARE
AT THE POINT AT THE. FIFTY
THANK YOU THEN THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP.
THANK YOU MODERATE HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NONE- MOVING
ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE WE SEE NONE. ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. NONE THERE AND MOVING ON
TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE INDIVIDUALLY FOR THOSE
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. FIFTY THANK
YOU TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FIFTY PLEASE GO AND HIT ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO
PLEASE. NO PARTICIPANTS ARE
QUEUING UP OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL MOVE TO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THIS BILL.
CENTER PAN. I THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU SETTLEMENT FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
ACTUALLY JUST A BRIEF COMMENT I
WOULD MAKE NOTE BECAUSE WE JUST
HEARD- SERRA LAVER'S BUILD THAT
I BELIEVE IN SB FIFTY IS SNOWED
AND ANALYSIS THAT ACTUALLY WE
WILL HAVE TOTAL ALIGNMENT IN
THE PAYMENT SYSTEMS I KNOW
ASKED A QUESTION BACK IN
EDUCATION WE HEARD THIS BILL SO
THE I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PAYMENT RATE WILL ACTUALLY BE
ALIGNED WITH- THE PROGRAMS AND
UNDER PART OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
SO JUST WANTED TO MAKE NOTE OF
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT BILLS AND QUESTIONS
HOW THEY THE WIND OR NOT AND-
WITH THAT- ESTIMATE THANK YOU
FOR BEING STILL FORD AND- WOULD
BE HAPPY TO MOVE IT AT THE
PROPER TIME. ANY COMMENTS ARE.
OKAY ARE CENTER LIMóN JULY TO
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK AN ITEM
OKAY SO WE HAVE A BY SENATOR
PAN AND ASCERTAIN PLEASE CALL
ROLL. SB FIVE THE MOTION IS
PASS BUT FOR BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS HER
TADO HI. FOR TITLE II JONES
JONES HI CORTESE ALL RIGHT
CORTEZ THE I. COM LONGER HI COM
LONGER I'D PAN NIGHT AND I. SO
THE VOTERS FIVE ZERO AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. ALL RIGHT OKAY.
NOW MOVING ON TO AGENDA SEVEN
SB FIVE SIX TWO BY CENTER
PORTANTINO FEEL FREE TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS- SB FIVE SIX TWO WILL
ELIMINATE SIGNIFICAN ARTIFICIAL
BARRIERS IMPOSED BY HEALTH
PLANS THAT ARE PREVENTING
FAMILIES FROM ACCESSING
BEHAVIOR HEALTH TREATMENT FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH AUTISM.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
CHILDREN WITH A WITH AUTISM WHO
RECEIVE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENT EARLY CAN SHOW
REMARKABLE PROGRESS I
UNDERSTAND I THINK IT'S THREE
TIMES. MMHM MORE COST EFFECTIVE
TO HAVE EARLY NTERVENTION IN
LATE INTERVENTION AND FOUR
TIMES MORE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
BENEFICIAL TO START EARLY SO
WE'RE REALLY INCREASING THE
CHANCES OF THESE YUNG PEOPLE
HAVING SUCCESS IN LIFE AND
REACHING THEIR FULL POTENTIAL
THE BILL ALSO CODIFIES THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR QUALIFIED
AUTISM SERVICE PROFESSIONALLY
PARA PROFESSIONAL. TO ENSURE
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE CITY
SIX TELL US THAT ONE IN FIFTY
NINE CHILDREN BORN TODAY ARE
DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM. EARLY
INTERVENTION IS THE KEY AS I
SAID BEFORE AND HELPING THESE
CHILDREN LIVE UP TO THEIR
POTENTIAL AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT IS CRITICAL. NOT ALL
CHILDREN WITH AUTISM ARE THE
SAME THEY RESPOND TO TREATMENT
DIFFERENTLY LIKE ALL CHILDREN
RESPOND TO THINGS DIFFERENTLY
GERMANY TREATMENT TAILORED TO
THEIR INDIVIDUAL NEEDS
PRESCRIBED BY THEIR PHYSICIAN.
OR PSYCHOLOGIST WHO KNOWS THEM
BEST NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
TREATMENT ALL TREATMENTS MAY
NOT BE APPROPRIATE FOR ALL
CHILDREN. EIGHT YEARS AGO SB
NINE FORTY SIX PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR AUTISM
FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH AUTISM.
IT HAS BEEN A VERY SUCCESSFUL
FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS BUT
OTHERS HAVE BEEN PREVENTED FROM
RECEIVING ITS BENEFITS BECAUSE
OF A DRAFTING ERROR AN
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS NOT EVERY
CHILD IS RECEIVING COVERAGE FOR
THE TREATMENT THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER PRESCRIBES THEM.
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
BEING DENIED COVERAGE FOR
MEDICALLY NECESSARY PHYSICIAN
PRESCRIBE EVIDENCE BASED
COVERAGE. THIS IS A COVERAGE
THEY OR THEIR EMPLOYERS HAVE
ALREADY PAID FOR BUT IT'S IN
TOO MANY CASES THE PARENTS ARE
STATE ARE LEFT TO COVER THE
COSTS OF THIS CRITICAL CARE.
ADDITIONALLY FOR MANY CHILDREN
THERE IS A SIX TO TWELVE MONTH
WAITING LIST FOR THE ONE
TREATMENT THAT HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERS. TREATMENT DELAYED IS
TREATMENT TONIGHT IN DEVELOPING
A WONDERFUL WONDERFUL CHILD TO
MINE BY EXPANDING THE TYPES OF
QUALIFIED ALREADY STATE
CERTIFIED HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
ELIGIBLE COVERAGE THIS BILL
WILL ADDRESS. THIS CRITICAL
SHORTAGE AND ALLOW FOR CHILDREN
TO RECEIVE THE TREATMENT AND
CONDITION HAS PRESCRIBED THE
BILL WILL ALSO ADDRESS
ROADBLOCKS THE COVERAGE FOR OUR
PARENTS WHO FOR REASONS OF WHY.
FAMILY PRESSURES CANNOT FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR CHILD'S
THERAPY SESSION OR WHOSE
CHILDREN HAVE TO RECEIVE
SERVICES AT OUR AFTER SCHOOL
DAY CARE SETTING. THE SITUATION
SHOULDN'T PRECLUDE COVERAGE FOR
MEDICALLY NECESSARY TREATMENT
WITH SB FIVE SIXTY TWO THEY
WON'T. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS JIM LANTRY FROM
THE D. I. R. COALITION OF
CALIFORNIAN ALISON FAN A
PARENT. OF A CHILD WITH AUTISM
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK
YOU CENTER PORTANTINO- WILL BE
MOVING ON TO A LEAD WITNESSES
AND- IN SUPPORT. AND JUST
REMINDED THE WILL BE LIMITING-
AT. THE TESTIMONY TO THREE
MINUTES EACH AT THE TOP PLEASE
SUPPORT NUMBER ONE PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
HI MY NAME IS JIM LANDRY THANK
YOU MANAGER SENATORS I'M WITH
C. D. R. FLOOR TIME COALITION-
A COALITION OF PARENTS AND
PROVIDERS TO ADVOCATE FOR
CHOICE OF TREATMENT FOR
CHILDREN WITH AUTISM. WE'VE
BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD BEFORE SO
THIS WILL SOUND FAMILIAR TO
MANY OF US ALL CALIFORNIANS
WITH AUTISM DESERVE THE BEST
DOCTOR OR PSYCHOLOGIST
PRESCRIBED MEDICALLY NECESSARY
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT
DESIGNED. SPECIFICALLY FOR
THEM. RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
CHILDREN WHO RECEIVE TREATMENT
EARLY RESPOND BETTER AND
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THE
TREATMENT **** TO THE NEEDS OF
THE CHILD IS IMPORTANT RESULTS
IN THE CHILD ATTAINING HIS OR
HER FULL POTENTIAL. YOU KNOW TO
CHILDREN WITH AUTISM ARE LIKE
WHAT WORKS FOR ONE CHILD MAY
NOT WORK FOR ANOTHER. UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW TREATMENT SHOULD
BE AN EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE
WHICH REQUIRES THREE THINGS
FIRST THE TREATMENT HAS TO BE
SUPPORTED BY RESEARCH. SECOND I
MUST USE THE CLINICIANS BEST
JUDGMENT AND THIRD IT MUST TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE SPECIFIC NEEDS
OF THE PATIENT. WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED MENTAL
HEALTH THIRTY ONE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE IT IMPRESSED
DISSIPATED THAT AUTISM WOULD BE
TREATED IN THE SAME MANNER AS
PHYSICAL ELEMENTS THIS DIDN'T
HAPPEN. IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB NINE
FORTY SIX WHICH MANDATED THAT
ALL PRESCRIBED MEDICALLY
NECESSARY EVIDENCE BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT TO
BE COVERED BY HEALTH INSURANCE.
AGAIN UNFORTUNATELY THIS DIDN'T
HAPPEN WHAT DID HAPPEN IS THAT
HEALTH INSURANCE WITH SOME
EXCEPTIONS COVERED ONE FORM OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT AB
EIGHT. OTHER FORMS OF EVIDENCE
BASED TREATMENTS WERE DENIED
COVERAGE. AS A RESULT PARENTS
OF CHILDREN WITH AUTISM
PRESCRIBE A DIFFERENT FORM TO
TREATMENT. WE'RE FACED WITH
THREE OPTIONS. FIRST WILL TO
PAY FOR THE- TREATMENT OUT OF.
YOU THOUGH THERE THEIR EMPLOYER
THAT ARE PAID FOR. AND MOST
PARENTS. SINGLE PARENTS AND LO
AND PARENTS THIS IS WAS AFFORD.
THE SECOND WAS THAT REGIONAL
CENTER TO PAY FOR THE TREATMENT
SINCE. IN SOME CASES THE SIX.
ABOUT A COUNTRY TO THE LEDGE.
INTENT OF GRASS NINE FORTY. THE
THIRD OPTION WAS JUST ACCEPT
THE ONE FORM OF THERAPY THAT
WAS COVERED. EVEN THOUGH IT
MIGHT NOT BE IDEAL OR MIGHT
EVEN BE DETRIMENTAL TO THE
CHILD. IT ALSO RESULTED IN A
LONGER TERM CARE. BECAUSE YOU
HEALTH INSURANCE CARRIER MORE
MONEY BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
COSTING THE CHILD TIME THAT CAN
NEVER BE RECOVERED. THIS BILL
WILL WRECK THAT AND FINE
ACHIEVED- LEGISLATIVE. MENTAL
HEALTH CARE BILL HAS BEEN
FORTY. I WANT TO POINT THAT THE
CORE. ARTISANS FOR. THIS BILL
ADDS ARE ALREADY CLASS. AS
MENTAL HEALTH. PROVIDERS THIS
IS INCLUDED IN SB EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE LAST YEAR. WHICH AMENDED
THE MENTAL HEALTH PARITY ACT.
UNDER SB FIVE SIXTY TWO THESE
QUALIFIED AND SUPERVISE
PROFESSIONALS WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE COVER TREATMENT. AND
ALLOW MORE CHILDREN TO RECEIVE
THIS ESSENTIAL TREATMENT. SB
FIVE SIXTY TWO ALSO INCREASES
THE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS REPAIR
PROFESSIONALS PROVIDING NINETY
BE SERVICES. OR BACKGROUND
CHECKS AND CLOSES THE LOOP THAT
ALLOWED IN CARE TO DO NOT COVER.
THE BILL BY NUMBER ORGAN. IN
PROTECT PARENTS OF IN NEED
THESE ARE BASED TREATMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY I'M HAPPY TO
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU I WILL BE MOVING ON TO LEAD
SUPPORT NUMBER TWO PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
HELLO BY NAME IS ALLISON SPAIN-
AND I'M THE MOTHER OF I HAVEN'T
SEEN A FOUR YEAR OLD BOY
DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM- JUST
BEFORE HE TURNED TO. I MEAN I'M
HAPPY BE HEARD TODAY TO SHOW
MUCH. FOR FIVE SIXTY TWO. AFTER
I HAVEN'T I'VE BEEN WITH.
BEHAVIOR THERAPY WITH THE ONLY
TREATMENT ON. THAT WAS OFFERED
TO US BY INSURANCE. AND IT
WITHOUT THE BILL BE OPTION I
WOULD WEAR AT THE TIME- WE ARE.
TO EIGHTY FOR OUR PER WEEK- WE
DID AB. FOR OVERS. AND NOTICED
VERY LITTLE IMPROVE MY AND ALL
AREAS OF ITEM ABOUT. I WOULD
SAY OVER THE X. WAS COUNTER.
AND BECAUSE AN INCREASE AND
ACTED BE. AND THE THING THINK
EVER. FEARS INCREASED. AND
THAT'S THE- I AM. I WOULD
BASICALLY DOWN HIS. AND ONE
WHERE- I REACHED OUT TO THE END
COMPANY FOR OTHER OPTION AND
WAS. THE EVIDENCE BASED ABOUT
PAYER HERE IN. CA PROJECT. WE
DID ALL THE VALUE. AND PAPER
AND I SPOKE AT LENGTH WITH THE
THERAPIST YOU WOULD BE WITH
I'VE BEEN. AND WE VERY EXCITED
STARTED- INSURANCE TONIGHT SIR.
AT THE LAST MINUTE- SHORT
BECAUSE IT WAS EIGHTY- EVEN
THOUGH BY LAW THEY WORK FOR TO
IT. WE CAN DO WE CAN WITH THE-
OF. AND EVEN THOUGH BECAUSE TO
PAY. OUT OF POCKET. THE
THERAPIST WORKS WITH I BEEN ONE
ON IT'S SORT OF IN THE- THERAPY
AND MANY YEARS AGO X. OF X.
WILL TELL OF ALL. AND. THIS
TYPE OF THERAPY IS ONLY ABOUT
TO EIGHT HOURS A MONTH. OF ONE
ON ONE TIME AND I AT THE AND
INCLUDED IN EVERY STEP. I'M
GIVING ADVICE PERCENT AND
STRUCK. ON WHAT TO DO WITH I'VE
BEEN THROUGHOUT THE WEEK-
EVIDENT BASED ABOUT THERAPY IS
TAYLOR TO MEET I'VE BEEN. I
I'VE BEEN. IN THE YEAR WE
FIFTY. THERAPY THE NOTHING
SHORT OF MY- I DON'T USE THAT
LIGHTLY I. HERE IMPROVED BRAG.
WHICH I LED TO A IN THE FONG.
WHICH HAS LED TO. ENGAGED
ENTIRELY OF LEARN AND ALL
DEVELOP TO ME. DOESN'T TEACHING
COMMUNICATE. MOTOR DOES ALMOST
HEALTH AND CO. ABILITIES. I'VE
BEEN OUT THE SKILL TO BUILD
REAL. WITH ADULTS AND- WE'RE
STILL WORKING FUNCTIONAL
COMMUNICATE. BUT HE HAS COME
SUCH A LONG GIVEN THE THAT
HARDLY OUT ALL ONE YEAR AGO. AB
WORK SYSTEM- NOT FOR AN-
DEVELOPMENTAL WORK FOR MY SON
AND I KNOW IT WORKS OTHER
PEOPLE. I BELIEVE THAT AND I
HAVE TO GO BROKE PAYING OUT OF
POCKET. FOR WHAT I KNOW A LIFE
CHANGING TREATMENT. SEE NON
THEY'RE MOVING ONTO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENTS
ONLINE CAN MODERATE IF YOU
PLEASE OPEN IT UP INDIVIDUALLY.
AND CAN YOU PLEASE LET US KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN THE
QUEUE. CERTAINLY PAGE AND JOHN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
FOUR FIVE SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
PARTICIPANT AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. M. LINE THREE OH FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M SURE MEMBERS THERESA
ANDERSON WITH ART AND UCPE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE CLEAN UP.
THANK YOU WATER YOU HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WE
WILL NOW POLICY PROCESS- AND
LIMIT- JUST WANTED THREE
MINUTES EACH FOR THREE MINUTES
UP FROM ANY OPPOSITION- AND AT
THE MOMENT WE HAVE WITNESSES.
THAT ARE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THEN WILL BEGIN
WITH- THAT WITNESS NUMBER ONE
WE HAVE MLISSA CORTEZ FROM THE
CENTER FOR AUTISM AND RELATED
DISORDERS BY PHONE AND THEN- WE
ALSO HAVE. WITNESS NUMBER TWO
MICHELLE HE'D OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS. DO WE HAVE MELISSA
AND OR MICHELLE ON THE LINE.
THIS IS MICHELLE HYDE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS AND HERE OKAY
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- MY
NAME'S MICHELLE HYDE AND I'M
BOARD CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR
ANALYST- ALSO CHAIR OF THE
PUBLIC POLICY COMMITTEE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS. I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND THE SPONSOR
CORRECTIVE MEETING YESTERDAY
DISCUSSING OUR CONCERNS- CAL
ABBOTT IS CONCERNED REGARDING
THE REVISION OF DEFINITION OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT. TO
INCLUDE DEVELOPMENTAL AND
RELATIONSHIP BASED
INTERVENTIONS FOR WHICH THERE
IS LITTLE EVIDENCE F EFFICACY.
IF SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE EXISTS
FOR PARTICULAR INTERVENTION FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM
SPECTRUM DISORDER IT WOULD BE
COVERED UNDER THE EXISTING A
MANDATE. THAT STATE OTHER
EVIDENCE BASED INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS. THAT IS CURRENTLY
INCLUDED IN THE DEFINITION OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
MAKING SB FIVE SIXTY TWO
UNNECESSARY. AND DISCUSSION
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR
THEY INDICATE THAT SB FIVE SIX
EACH YEAR DOES NOT EXPAND
PROVIDER QUALIFICATION. AND
THIS IS THE CASE THEN WE
QUESTION THE NEED FOR THE BILL
HOWEVER THE ANALYSIS INDICATES
THE BILL DOES EXPAND
QUALIFICATIONS WERE QUALIFIED
OCCIDENT SERVICE PROFESSIONAL.
WHICH IS CONCERNING. WE ARE
ALSO CONCERNED WITH REFERENCES
TO EDUCATION AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT THAT EXIST IN
THE BILL AS IT UNCLEAR WHAT.
EDUCATION WOULD BE SINCE
THERE'S NO UNDERGRADUATE
GRADUATE PROGRAMS OR CURSED
COURSE WORK IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT. THIS IS ABOUT
ENSURING HIGH QUALITY EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTION FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATION AND MAINTAINING THE
INTEGRITY. OF THE AUTISM
INSURANCE MANDATE. CONTRA TO
THE PER CODE. THERE IS NO AB
MANAB. AT THE END NOW CORRECT
LISTED NUMBER OF OTHER
TREATMENT MODALITIES. THAT ARE
EVIDENCE BASED AND ARE
THEREFORE COVERED BY COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE. MANY OF THE ISSUES
RAISED THROUGH THIS LEGISLATION
CAN AND SHOULD BE ADDRESSED BY
A STATE REGULATORY OVERSIGHT
BODY. WE URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSSION ABOUT
CONCERNS RAISED BY THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I WANTED TO GO AHEAD AND
JUST MAKE SURE THAT- WE DIDN'T
MISS OUR- FIRST WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. FORMOSA CORTEZ'S
SHE ON THE LINE. OKAY IT SEEMS
THAT SHE'S NOT ON THE LINE WE
WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE SIX
TWO WE HAVE NINE HERE IN. FORTY
TWO ZERO THREE- RICK NOT MOVING
ON TO ROOM TWO TWENTY FORTY SEE
NONE- NOW WILL BE MOVING ON TO
THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE AND MODERATE IF YOU CAN
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE TO
THOSE- LOOKING TO- TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP FIVE SIX
TWO. AND PLEASE CALL THOSE
INDIVIDUALLY. AND I JUST WANTED
TO SCREAM FOR SIZE A NAME-
ORGANIZATION AND A POSITION ON
THIS BILL SB FIVE SIX TWO.
THANK YOU IT IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO OPPOSE. THIS IT. FIVE SIX
TWO. HI GOOD AFTERNOON- TERM
MEMBERS REALLY SUCH AS MILLER
SAYS BUT AS AN ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MOVING ON
TO THE NEXT. AND ONE MOMENT
PLEASE AND THE NEXT ONE IS
MELISSA CORTEZ PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON OUR MEMBERS AND SHARE
AYE I APOLOGIZE FOR I THINK I
HAD THE WRONG DIAL IN NUMBER-
MELISSA CORTEZ A GOVERNMENTAL
ADVOCATE REPRESENTING THE
CENTER FOR AUTISM AND RELATED
DISORDERS. CARDS PRIMARY
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL IS TO
CHANGE THE DEFINITION OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT.
CURRENT LAW ALREADY REQUIRES
COMPETENT FOR COVERAGE FOR ALL
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT. I
WANT TO GO BACK AND EXPLAIN WHY
THE ORIGINAL MANDATE WAS
DRAFTED THAT WAY. AT THAT TIME
DMH THE NGO Y. HEADLINE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS WITH SOME
OF THE LARGE HEALTH PLAN. IN
THOSE AGREEMENTS THE HEALTH
PLANS AGREED TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR APPLIED BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS. AND THIS WAS ONLY
AFTER LARGE VOLUMES OF THE NILE
COURT ROUTINELY OVERCHARGED OR
LION ARE. BUT THOSE SETTLEMENT
DIDN'T COVER ALL HEALTH PLANS
AND THEY REQUIRE TREATMENT BY
LIKE HE'S PROVIDERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IN CALIFORNIA
ABA PROVIDERS ARE NATIONALLY
CERTIFIED BUT NOT LICENSED BY
THE STATE. BECAUSE OF THIS SB
NINE FORTY SIX DID VERY
IMPORTANT THINGS. CHOIR
COVERAGE BY ALL COMMERCIAL
PLANS AND IT TIED PROVIDER
REQUIREMENTS TO EXISTING DDS
REGULATION. IS BAD ALREADY ALL
DONE ALL THE WORK AND OUTLINES
WHAT THOSE QUALIFICATIONS
SHOULD BE. TEN YEARS AGOWHEN
THAT LAW WAS BEING DEBATED THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WHERE
THEY'RE ASKING THAT WERE TRYING
TO BE INCLUDED. AND WHILE THEY
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. WE DO NOT
WANT TO CLOSE THE DOOR TO A
MERGING MENTALITIES AND THAT'S
WHY THAT BILL WAS DRAFTED TO
INCLUDE ALL OTHER EVIDENCE
BASED INTERVENTION PROGRAM.
THIS MEANS THAT IF AND WHEN
THERE'S ENOUGH RESEARCH TO FIND
AN INTERN AND INTERVENTION IT'S
EVIDENCE BASED. IT IS COVERED
BY LAW. THE NATIONAL AUTISM
CENTER'S NATIONAL STANDARDS
PROJECT LIST RELATIONSHIP BASED
TREATMENT AS A MERGING IT LIST
FOR TIME UNESTABLISHED. IN
ADDITION A TROOPER RECORD FOR
AN ALMOST IDENTICAL BILL TWO
YEARS AGO SAID THERE IS LIMITED
EVIDENCE THAT RELATIONSHIP
DEVELOPMENTAL INTERVENTION
IMPROVED COMMUNICATION ALSO
ACTION ACADEMIC PLACEMENTS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT ABA VERSUS
FOR TIME. THIS IS ABOUT
PRESERVING OF STANDARD OF CARE
THAT IS BASED ON SCIENCE AND
RESEARCH. MAKING THIS CHANGE
COULD HAVE A DETRIMENTAL EFFECT
IF KIDS ARE MOVED INTO LESS
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT. SO FOR
THAT REASON WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO STRIVE TO CHANGE
THE DEFINITION OF THE H. T. R.
VOTE NO ON THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE WE WILL CONTINUE
WITH THE- PUBLIC COMMENT ON IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL-
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE LET US
KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
WINNING Q. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. OKAY WELL MOVING ON I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OFFER ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. THREE NINE- TO-
PORTANTINO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES I WOULD THANK YOU-
MADAM CHAIR YOU KNOW THIS ISN'T
BEEN A FASCINATING THREE YEAR
JOURNEY FOR ME LISTENING TO
PEOPLE WHO SHARE THE SAME
MISSION SAYING ALMOST IDENTICAL
THINGS WERE COMING UP WITH
DIFFERENT CONCLUSIONS- THIS IS
ABOUT. MAKING SURE A DOCTOR CAN
PRESCRIBE AN EVIDENCE BASED
MEDICALLY NECESSARY TREATMENT
TO HELP KIDS. THE FACT THAT IT
IS GETTING SUCH OPPOSITION FROM
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES-
EMPHASIZES BUT THIS IS NOT
ABOUT. WHAT SOME OF THE
COMMENTS ARE MAKING IT ABOUT
AND I IT'S BEEN FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
CARE ABOUT KIDS WHO TALK PAST
EACH OTHER. AND I JUST I'M
FRUSTRATED AS A DAD. AS A
LEGISLATOR AS A POLICY MAKER
AND IF YOU REMEMBER LAST YEAR
WE- SENATOR STONE WAS BROUGHT
TO TEARS THINKING ABOUT HIS
DAUGHTER AND HIS FAMILY HAVING
TO PAY OUT OF POCKET FOR
TREATMENT BIKINIS
GRANDDAUGHTER. THIS IS ABOUT
FAMILIES WHO. FIND A BENEFIT
FROM THIS TREATMENT FROM
MULTIPLE TREATMENTS. BUT
BECAUSE OF A FLAW IN THE
DRAFTING HAS CREATED A
MONOPOLY. AND PEOPLE DON'T WANT
TO GIVE UP THE MONOPOLY. AND I
JUST THINK WE NEED TO EMBRACE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
HEALTHCARE. WE NEED TO EMBRACE
THE INTERVENTION OF OUR KIDS.
AND WE NEED TO PASS THIS BILL
AND IT NEEDS TO GET SIGNED AND
WE JUST NEED TO BRING CARE. AND
LOVE TO. TELL THE LITTLE ONES
WHO NEEDED AS EARLY IN THEIR
LIFE AS POSSIBLE AND-
YESTERDAY'S CONVERSATION WAS
VERY VERY PRODUCTIVE- I HOPE IT
CONTINUES. BECAUSE I HEARD A
LOT OF COMMON GROUND FROM THE
TWO SIDES EVEN THOUGH. NONE OF
THAT WAS NOT EXPRESSED TODAY-
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATED THE
EFFORT FROM THE CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I REALLY
WANT TO GET THIS BILL SIGNED
THIS YEAR. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO WE HAVE A MOTION-
PRESIDENT BY CENTER CORTESE ON-
SB FIVE SIX TWO AND- SECRETARY
TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
FIVE SIX TO THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH HER
TADO NINE FOR TITLE III JONES.
JONES I CORTESE I CORTEZ THE I.
COM MARKER. KAMLAGER I PAN
NIGHT AND BY. THE VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO AND THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND UP NEXT WE
HAVE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER NINE WE
HAVE SENATOR SKINNER HERE TO
PRESENT ON SB THREE FIVE FOR. A
CENTER SKINNER PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
PLEASE TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT TO
YOU SB THREE FIFTY FOUR.
CHILDREN DO BETTER WHEN THEY
LIVE WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT CHILDREN
YOUR HOUSE TO FAMILY MEMBERS OR
THEIR RELATIVES HAVE BETTER
ATTACHMENTS TO CARE GIVERS CAN
SUFFER FEWER BEHAVIORAL AND
EDUCATIONAL CHALLENGES. MANY
CHILDREN ARE FOSTER SYSTEM
HOWEVER HAVE RELATIVES WHO WERE
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED OR HAVE
A PAST CONVICTION. AND
UNFORTUNATELY UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT RULES
THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
TREATED PER JUDICIOUSLY. EVEN
WHEN. THEIR CRIMINAL RECORD MAY
BE VERY OLD YEARS PASSED FOR IT
WOULD NOT IMPACT THE SAFETY OF
THE CHILD AND DISBAND PREVENTS.
THAT FAMILY MEMBER OR EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBER FROM BEING ABLE
TO BE THE CHILD CARE GIVER. NOW
THERE'S A RACIAL IMPACT TO THIS
WERE FIVE LENDS ENACT BLACK
CHILDREN OR TWO POINT EIGHT
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. WHAT NEXT
TO OLDER AND ARE ALL. HIGHER
LIKELIHOOD ADDITIONALLY AND AS
WE KNOW BLACK AND BROWN
FAMILIES ARE MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WITH A PAST
CONVICTION. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
SB FIFTY THREE FIFTY FORCED TO
REMOVE BARRIERS IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM TWO CHILDREN BEING
HOUSED WITH RELATIVES AND NON
RELATIVES STANDARD FAMILY
MEMBERS. THAT MAY HAVE A PRIOR
CONVICTION PROVIDED THAT THAT
CONVICTION DOES NOT ENDANGER
THE CHILD'S- SO THAT ITS ITS
PURPOSE THERE- RECENT
AMENDMENTS WERE- WE'RE WORKING
ON AND ARE YOU GOING TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL THAT HAVE
BROUGHT ON SUPPORT OF SOME KEY-
SUPPORTERS WHO ARE YOU HERE
FROM WHO YOU WILL HEAR FROM. IN
THE- AS THEY CALL IN BUT LET ME
NOW TURN TO MY WITNESSES WHO
ARE VYING NHà CORALS FROM
STARTING OVER INCORPORATED IN
KHAKI SANDERLING FROM THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. TO
HAVE KATHY ON THE CALL. YEAH I
BELIEVE THE QUARRELS WILL BE
SPEAKING FIRST FOR AFFECTS YOU
FROM ONLINE I'LL I'LL GIVE HER
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO JUMP IN. WE
HAVE. LEVINE LOW NO NEW COAL
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN TO THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BONITA QUORUM AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR FOR THE LONG HAUL
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING AND
REENTRYSERVICE PROVIDING
ORGANIZATION WHAT OPERATED FOR
ABOUT ELEVEN YEARS OLD ALMOST
TWELVE HUNDRED PEOPLE. BUT
HOUSING RELATED SERVICES. LIKE
MOST PEOPLE IT WRONG WORK IT'D
BEEN MUSLIM WHERE YOU THINK
WELL PERSONALLY PROFESSIONAL I
GOT MY HAVE BEEN FIVE AND PLACE.
ON THE VALUE OF THE- BOTTOM OF
THE OKAY INDEPENDENT POWER.
ABOUT FOUR YEARS BOB CARE. AS A
YOUNG. I HAVE THREE CHILDREN
WORDS OUT- YEAH AND I THOUGHT I
TOLD BACK TO AND- THE CARD IS.
TOTAL THREE NOT. ALL RIGHT.
YEAH TWENTY YEARS AGO ACTUALLY
THREE YEARS AGO. HI THAT. YOU
WITH AND THE ART CLASS THE
RESTORE COUNTY YEAH I'M THIRTY
YEARS AWAY. IN I'M A
GRANDMOTHER I'M ACROSS IT FOR
I'M NOT CO FOUNDER OF THE NON
AND I HAVE ME OUT BUT I THOUGHT
WAS A LOT OF PRIVILEGE. TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS MY GO FROM THE-
HOWEVER. OKAY. I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S NOTHING MORE
SACRED THAN OUR CHILDREN. BUT
IT WAS TO THE POINT THAT IT
FELT LIKE NOTHING ELSE
MATTERED- I WAS THIRTY YEARS
AGO AND THAT'S NOT WHO I AM.
AND IT WASN'T JACK. JACK OUR
FAMILY. ALMOST HALF OF THE
CHILDREN. BECAUSE HAVE A- IN
COURT YOU KNOW HOW. THE CARD
RECORD. AND SO. THE DISPARITY
STUDY SO THE CRIMINALS SYSTEM
AS IT IS MORE AND MORE OFTEN
OUR FAMILIES ARE IMPACTED AND
END UP IN. OUR FAMILY PLAYED.
THANK YOU COULD BOB. BOSTON
THAT. WELL I WHY IS IT THAT
RUNS JUST LOOKING A CRIMINAL WE
THE AGENCY. I WOULD. AND THAT'S
WHY WE THE DEAL BELIEVE FOUR I
LOVED IT. I OF THE INDIVIDUAL.
BRANCH OUT THERE THREE YEARS
SHE SHARED HER EXPERIENCE WITH
ME ON THE ONE COMMON WHAT HELLO.
I'LL SHE'S THE ONE WHO. YEAH
QUITE ONE. ANYONE WITH HER
BEDROOM AND SHE HAS A WARRANT.
THE. ONE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED.
COMPLAIN ABOUT ONE OF THE
FOLLOWING MONDAY YEAH. SHE HER.
WE'RE TAKING AWAY IN. AS
GRANDMOTHER THAT OPENED THE
BECAUSE THE PROMO FOR HER.
THREE YEARS FIVE ZERO DOESN'T A.
HELLO HI OF STORY. LET KNOW
THAT THREE FIFTY FOUR TO WORK
FOR. IN BROWN'S AND ALL THE
CALIFORNIA AND OUTSIDE THE
BOOKS. THREE FIFTY FOUR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MOVING ON OUR TO
PARTNER TWO K. S. AND ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. I AM THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
FAMILY MAKE ON A LOOK AT TELL
ME WHAT FOR DIRECT OF THOSE.
CDBG PLEASE TO START SUPPORT
THREE FIFTY FOR I APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR- HER
STAFF AND THE CO SPONSORS AND
WORKING WITH OUR ORGANIZATION.
THE CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER AND
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS IN THE AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU'D BE IMPRESSED I'M REALLY
HONORED TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY. TO SUPPORT OF MOST
OF THECOMMENTS BY SENATOR
SKINNER AND THE SQUIRRELS
REGARDING THE DISPROPORTION OUT
EACH DIFFERENT HOW WATER AND I
THOUGHT THE AFFECT OF AN EQUITY
THAT ARE UNDERLYING CRIMINAL
DOCTORS THAT STANDS THAT
NEGATIVELY AFFECT RELATIVES
ESPECIALLY THOSEOF COLOR.
SEEKING TO CARE FOR CHILDREN
BROUGHT INTO CARE DUE TO ABUSE
OR NEGLECT AFTER THAT
HEARTBREAKING PLACES YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY. KERN COUNTY SO
WELFARE AGENCY PERSPECTIVE
THAT'S ALL OF THEM PARTLY
BECAUSE THAT WILL HELP COUNTIES
PLEASE MORE CHILDREN WITH
WELLNESS CARE GIVERS WHEN THEY
COME INTO FOSTER CARE. AS NOTED
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE FOR MUCH BETTER
WITH RELATIVES IN GENERAL AND
RELATIVES OF THE FIRST PAGE
COUNTY TURNED YOU BY LAW AND.
BEST PRACTICE FOR THESE
CHILDREN. ONE ARE THINKING OF
PLACES. WELL IT. AS PART OF THE
RE. FAMILY OUR CREW PROCESS.
ANY PERSON MEDINA HOME OR WHO
IS WHERE YOU BECAUSE IN THE-
MUST BE BACK. CHECKS I'M
PERSONALLY IN PATH CONVICTS. IN
OTHER THAN ON MY TRAFFIC BY. OR
MARROW. CONVICTION MY BE
GRANTED IN THE- OR THE WHOLE.
BE THIS IS A CASE BY CASE. I
DON'T ON IT FOR OF THE NAY OF
THE CALL. AS WELL AS THAT OF
COURSE IS TAKEN COMBAT TO SHOW
CHAIN. AND ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE
A STATE OF MY CAN BUY. FOR
THEIR REALLY CHILD. PROVIDE
DETAILED AND- THAT CAN. THE
THIRTY FOUR REQUIRE THAT MUST
ALL TAKE AWAY IS THE BEST INTO.
NOT EVERY EXEMPTS REQUEST
GRANTED AN APPROVAL FOR
RELATIVE TO BECOMING GIVER A
CHILD IS NOT GUARANTEED CHILD
WILL BE PLACED. IN RECENT YEARS
HE TO BE A HAS A IN BONTA
EFFORT. TO MAKE EVEN. FROM
COURT. FOR MINOR. AS WELL AS
CURRENT LONGER GO I DO. WITH
MORE CONSISTENT AND CLEAR OVER.
THIS TAKEN UP MESSAGE THAT I
DID THE REASON APPELLATE COURT
DECISION BECAUSE THEM YOU'RE
NOT. THAT THE CLEAR THE CURRENT
UNCONSCIOUS. WHAT TO INDIVIDUAL
THEATER AS THE TWO CARE. FOR
EACH BUT OR CHAU. IN THIS HOME
DECISION THE COURT THAT SOME
CONVICTED OF A CRIME. CONSIDER
NOT REFUNDABLE UNDER CAR RULES
MUCH BE GIVEN A CHANCE TO
REQUEST POTENTIAL RECEIVING. IF
THEY HAVE A PARENT LIKE
RELEASED WITH CHILD. YEAH ARE
YOU CONSIDERING AN EXACT UNDER
THE CORPORATE WHICH THE ADDS
LAW. WOULD ESTABLISH THAT LIKE
RELATIONS YOU THINK THAT YOUR
INNER WITH THAT SHOW. AS WELL
WITH THE ROLE AND CRY. AND
OTHER WITH OUR OF THAT WERE. WE
COULDN'T GET THAT ROAD WERE IT.
WILL BE BY THE TIME AND FAMILY
PROCESS THEIR KERR JOB IS PROUD
TO CARE. WHICH INCLUDES FAMILY
MEMBERS LAW OTHERS WERE IN THE
CHILD LIFE. IMPORTANTLY THE ME
TAKE BY CASE PROCTOR. THE
EXTENT THAT NOT AN AUTUMN
EXEMPTS WOULD NOT GUARANTEE
PLACEMENT WITH THAT PROJECT
HOME. IF A PRIVILEGE. RIGHT NOW
COUNTY CANCER. TIED WHEN IT
COMES TO CONSIDER. AFTER
RELATIVES CARE GIVER. EVEN IF
THE CRIMES LONG. AND THEY HAVE
CLEARLY. AND YOUR CABLE OF
PROVIDE THAT LOVING AND PATIENT.
WE LOOK FOR. AND EVEN WHEN IT'S
EXPRESS A DESIRE TO LIVE WITH
PERSON. CENTER BUT MY PARENTS.
ENCOURAGED ME ARE APPROVAL. AND
THE FACT. ASSESSMENT OF THE IN
PART IN DESIGNED. BERMAN PRISON
OR- BUT IT DON'T CARE. AS WELL
AS OTHER IN THE MAYBE. AN FOR
THAT PLACE AND TO PICK THE. SB
THREE FIFTY FOUR WILL. COUNTY
MAKE THAT CASE BY YOU FOR.
EXEMPTION ONE OF LICENSE BUT
IDENTIFY AS THAT. CHARACTER FOR
ITS- TODAY WE CANNOT DO THAT
PER CERTAIN CRIME. BUT THE
APPELLATE DECISION IS MADE UP
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO
SO. WE SUPPORT THIS CHANGE AS
THREE FIVE FOUR ONE. THE WAY
THAT. THEY CAN. ABOUT IT LIKE
NEVER. I THANK YOU. FOR YOUR-
AND I'M HAPPY AND ANY. PRIOR UP.
THANK YOU. TO YOU. FOR JUST
HERE TODAY AND WILL ON TO PAY
COMMENT AND SO BEGIN WITH
FORTY. ZERO THREE AND- ROOM-
TWENTY FOUR SEEN ON THEIR- UP
THE TOLD- PUBLIC LINE FOR
THOSE- WAITING TO TESTIFY INTO
OF SB THREE FIVE FOUR MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THOSE
INDIVIDUALLY AND- LET US KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE WAITING IN
THE QUEUE. HERE WE CURRENTLY
HAVE SIX PEOPLE QUEUING UP. IN
SUPPORT AND OUR FIRST LINE IS
TWO FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
A. B. SANTOS ON BEHALF OF AT
THE AYE YOU CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING COUNTY SOCIAL
SERVICES. I'M SORRY PREVENTING
COUNTY CHILDREN'S WELFARE
SERVICES SOCIAL WORKER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU UNTIL NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE TO
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PINE TO NINETY NINE IS YOUR
PHONE ON MUTE. WELL NO RESPONSE
WE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE THREE
ZERO NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JERRY MEMBERS CRYSTAL
GET OFF ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. ON TO
THE NEXT CALLER MODERATOR.
THANK YOU AND THAT'S LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SURE MEMBERS AND WE
CENTERS WITH MILLER SAYS BUT
IT'S AN ASSOCIATE ON BEHALF OF
RESTORE JUSTICE AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER.
AND THAT IS COMING FROM LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUPREME COURT
CASE FROM THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND STRONG
RECORDED WITH BELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. AND
THAT'S TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS
IS AN AUTO INDUSTRY- INTO A
LYFT REENTRY PROJECT AND ALL OF
US ARE NOT ENOUGH ANGELES AND
LONG BEACH AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU THAT'S TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS WE DON'T TO GO
WELL NOW WITH THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS INITIATIVE RIVERSIDE
AND STARTING OVER AND WE'RE
SUPPORT YEAH SB THREE FIFTY
FOUR. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU AND THAT'S
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR TITLE I MEMBERS
THIS IS KERRY AND CAROL HINES
ON BEHALF OF THE TO DEL MAR
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
LOS ANGELES. I EXPRESSING
STRONG SUPPORT SB THREE FIFTY
FOUR AS AMENDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU OUR NEXT CALLER. AND THAT
COMES TO MIND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO
THIS IS ADAM WHETHER KING I AM
THE CHAIR OF THE SOCIAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE
AT THE UNIVERSALIST UNITARIAN
CHURCH OF RIVERSIDE. ALSO
MEMBER OF ALL OF US WHO NINE
RIVERSIDE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. AND THAT COMES TO MIND
TO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS TERRA RESTORED
ON THE CALIFORNIA RESIDENT IN
AUM I WOULD TRYING TO EARN AN
ALMOND FOR SUPPORT S. B. FIVE.
THREE FIVE FOUR SIX THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU AND THAT
COMES TO MIND TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ERIN MATTHEW I'M A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND I JUST
WANTED TO VOICE MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE FIVE FOUR.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU AND THAT COMES TO MIND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BRETT
SALLY MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF BAD
NOBODY WITH THE NEEDLES- WE
WANT TO DO I'M SURE STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE FIFTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU AND THAT
COMES FROM LINE TO SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GOING
TO GO. I'M STARTING OVER AND I
SUPPORT SB THIRTY FIVE FORMER.
BECAUSE RELATED PLACEMENT YOU
KNOW WE'RE JUST NOT TAKING LAKE
MICHIGAN ARE WE BEING A
PRIORITY TO KEEP FAMILIES
TOGETHER THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU AND NOW
TO LINE OF. TWO SIXTY. I'M SURE
THAT WAS THE LAST OF MY MISTAKE
TO THE LINE OF THREE TEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS-
CHAPLAIN GARCIA FROM CAT NINE
ONE ONE AND WE SUPPORT SB THREE
FIVE FOUR. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU AND AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO. BUT
YOUR SUPPORT AND OUTLINED AT
THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ADELINE ADDRESS
ON THE POLICY FELLOW WITH
STARTING OVER INC AND RIVERSIDE
ALL THE TURN ON AND I WANTED TO
VOICE OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL OF COLORS ON THE-
LINE. WE HAVE TWO MORE OKAY.
WE'LL TAKE THE NEXT ONE. THANK
THREE HUNDRED AND SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THREE HUNDRED AND SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
HIS NEIGHBOR MEANS THE POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT THE CHILDREN USE AND
AFTER KAREN LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTAL CLASSROOM. WORK
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO GET IT HERE
YOU. KEY POINTS OUT AN
ORGANIZATION A POSITION. YES
THIS IS READ- WHEN THE- IF I
JUST THE TABLE ON THE YOUTH
ORGANIZED- WHY DID YOU KNOW B.
I. AS THE POOR- SB THREE FIFTY
FOUR I KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER-
YOU KNOW AND ONLY BE CLEAR ONLY
BECAUSE- THANK YOU THANK YOU
ARE JUST TAKING NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL. WE PROVIDE THANK YOU ON
TO THE NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. RIGHT A
SO WHAT THIS MOMENT HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WE
WILL NOW OFFER POLICY PROCESS
TO HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION.
AND WE HAVE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE TO TESTIFY BUT
WILL. LOOK WILL OPEN UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
BEGINNING WITH ROOM FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE SEEN NONE- ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEN ON THERE AS
WELL- MOVING ON TO BE A
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENTS LINE
FOR THOSE. WANTING TO TESTIFY
AT. IN OPPOSITION TO US BEFORE
FIVE THREE THREE FIVE FOUR I
APOLOGIZE. AND IF MODERATE IF
YOU CAN PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE
AND CALLED THE- INDIVIDUALS-
WHAT TO TESTIFY. SURE IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THREE FIVE
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR- SO SEEN NO
OPPOSITION I WANTED TO GO
BEFORE WAIT. COME TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS I WANTED TO STOP
THANK SENATORS SKINNER FOR- FOR
WORKING WITH WHAT ARE COMMITTEE
AND WITH MEMBERS- TO DRESS YOU
KNOW ANY CONCERNS OR WHAT THAT
WERE RAISED DURING THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. OF THE
AUTHOR KNOWS ALL ALL BE STAYING
OFF THIS BILL AT THIS TIME
HOWEVER I A WATER MONITOR THE
BILL AS IT MOVES ALONG AND- AND-
SEE IF THERE IF THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO SUPPORT
THE BILL WHEN IT WHEN IT COMES
BACK. I'M SURE THAT IT WILL-
AND AT THIS MOMENT I WANT TO
OPEN IT UP TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. STE
SENATOR PAN AND THEN THE MISTER
VICE CHAIR. OKAY MISTER BAXTER.
MAKE IT YOUR OWN SEARCH HERE I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS FIRST OF ALL I HAD
SOME REALLY STRONG CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL- TWO WEEKS AGO-
BUT AGAIN THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND COMING
UP WITH THESE GREAT AMENDMENTS
I THINK- THEY MOVE THE BILL IN
A POSITIVE DIRECTION YOUR
WITNESS DID A GREAT JOB- FROM
CEDAR BDA YOU KNOW TALKING
ABOUT THE BILL AND TALK ABOUT
THE PROTECTIONS FOR THE
CHILDREN. WHICH I THINK WE ALL
ARE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT HERE ON
THAT- YOUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
I WANT TO GIVE THEM A SHOUT OUT
YOU CAN JUST- THE EMOTION IN
THEIR VOICES AS THEY'RE TRYING
TO CALL THROUGH AND- AND- TELL
THEIR STORY IN THE LITTLE BIT
OF TIME THAT THEY HAD TO TELL
THAT STORY- I. AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THE MOST. IMPORTANT AND
SAFE PLACE. FOR CHILD AGO IS
WITH ANOTHER FAMILY MEMBER- I
ALSO AGREE THAT. YOU KNOW A
FIVE YEAR OLD MISTAKE OR THIRTY
YEAR OLD MISTAKE DOESN'T
DEFINE. THE REST OF YOUR LIFE
AND OR YOUR ABILITY TO BE
RESPONSIBLE. I THINK SOMETIMES
IT THAT STORY CAN ACTUALLY BE A
POSITIVE ROLE MODEL. FOR THESE
CHILDREN. TO KNOW THAT THEY
ARE- WITH AN ADULT. THAT LOVES
THEM AND CARES FOR THEM AND HAS
HAD TO OVERCOME. SOME A
NEGATIVE LIFE EXPERIENCES. SO I
THINK THAT'S A POWERFUL. TOOL
ADDITIONAL TOOL IT IS NOT EVEN
TALKED ABOUT AND ANALYSIS. AND
I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT- AND SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND I'M
HOPING THAT IT HAS A- IF IT
DOES BECOME LAW THAT IT HAS A
POSITIVE OUTCOME FOR THESE
FAMILIES. AND THAT THE STORIES
WILL GET TOLD MD ARE
INSPIRATIONAL ENCOURAGING TO
OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE- YOU KNOW
PART OF THIS. LIFE EXPERIENCE
AND WE CAN HAVE MORE SUCCESS
STORIES. THANK YOU MISTER
MAESTRO MOVING ON TO SENATOR
PAN AND THEN A CENTER CORTESE.
THANK YOU AND- SESSION- I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR. WORKING WITH-
THE EXTREMELY DETAILED
ADVOCATES SAND THE WELFARE
DIRECTORS ON THE BILL AND- AND
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS I DO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE AN EXCELLENT
ALSO CLARIFIED. OF COURT
APPEALS A RULING WHICH IS LAW
SO NOTICES FOR ANYONE WHO HAS
ANY QUESTIONS THE ACTUAL LAW
AND STATE RIGHT NOW. DECLARES
THAT SOME OF THESE RESTRICTIONS
WHICH WERE LISTING IN THIS BILL
ARE ACTUALLY READY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL SO THAT THEY
COULD NOT THEY WOULD NOT HOLD
UP ANYWAY IN COURT THAT THAT'S
THE FINAL RULING RIGHT THERE'S
NO FURTHER APPEAL OF THAT
PARTICULAR RULING AT THE- IT
WAS. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THAT IS YES THE CARD IS NO ONE
ELSE IS TAKING A BREAK THANK
YOU. I THINK THAT IT'S- HELLO.
FIRST OF ALL YOU SAY IS THAT I
KNOW THAT BOTH YOU AND I- THOSE
VALUE SAY THAT NOTE THIS CHILD
SAFETY IS OUR BIRTHRIGHT THE
MOST THE TOP CONCERN RIGHT AT
THE CHILDREN'S SAFETY WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT CHILDREN'S SAFETY
THOUGH IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT.
YEAH HOUSE SAFE HOME IS AND
AGAIN YOU KNOW WE CAN TALK TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT DOES AN EXPERT
YOU KNOW HAVING A CRIMINAL
RECORD HOW UNSAFE THAT REALLY
MAKE THE HOME. AT THE END AND
THE NATURE BUT ALSO THE FACT IS
THAT PART OF CHILD SAFETY IS
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY IN THE
HOME WHERE THEY HAVE THE
OPTIMAL OPPORTUNITY FOR. THEIR
HEALTH AND THEIR GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT WHICH IS USUALLY
USUALLY IN MOST CASES A
RELATIVE'S HOME SOMEONE WHO HAS
THAT CONNECTION WITH THEM AND
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW THE WAY
THESE AND THEN BALANCE THAT AND
TO MOVE FORWARD SO. I ALWAYS
DID APPRECIATE THAT THAT WAS
YOUR INTENT AND EVEN THE-
PREVIOUS ITERATION OF THE BILL
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU WORK WITH
THE WELFARE DIRECTORS AS WELL
TO ADDRESS THIS IN THE CHILD
ADVOCATES. AND WITH WITH THOSE
PARTICULAR CHANGES AND ALSO
RECOGNIZING AGAIN D. WHAT THE
CASE LAW IS AS WELL AND THE
FACT. WE'RE TRYING TO THAT WERE.
CAN I THAT CASE LAW. AS WELL.
ASSEMBLY I WILL BE FAVOR OF
YOUR BILL AND ALL MOVE AT THE-
TIME. THANK YOU. SENATE ACCORD.
YOU'RE THINKING SURE I'LL BE
SUPPORTING BILL AS AMENDED-
RIGHT PREACH THE INTENT OF THE
BILL TREMENDOUSLY IN TERMS OF-
RELATIVE PLACEMENT IN TERMS OF
FAMILY PLACEMENT IMAGES SPENT
TWELVE YEARS ON THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SO MUCH
THAT TIME BUT SHARING THE
SOCIAL SERVICES COMMITTEE
THERE- THE HER THERE ARE MANY
MANY REASONS SO. TO KEEP GOING
DOWN THIS PATH- NOT THE LEAST
OF WHICH IS SAID. NOT OF ZERO
PLACEMENT IS HAPPENING IN A LOT
OF SITUATIONS- DESPITE- THE
LAWS THAT THAT REQUIRE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR PLACEMENT- IT IN AND-
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING BUT WASN'T
HAPPY TO MY HOME COUNTY IN I
DON'T HAVE TO SAY TO FOLKS IN
GENERAL I'M NOT THE EXPERT HELP
EVEN THOUGH I DID SERVE AT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IT'S BEEN A
LOT OF TIME IN DEEP IMMERSION.
I'M NOT HOLD MYSELF OUT AS AN
EXPERT AS EXPERT AS SOME OF THE
FOLKS WHO HAVE TESTIFIED ON THE
BILL TODAY BUT I WILL SAY-
THAT. IF YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE HARM THAT CAN OCCUR TO THE
CHILD. YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENS. ABSENT THIS POTENTIAL
ROLE TO PLACEMENT- THAT'S
BECAUSE COLD OUT HERE- IN IT
AND I WON'T GO TO THE NEW RATE
THE LIST OF THINGS THAT. I
THINK WE ALL KNOW HOW PLEASED-
IN THE FACT TO- HOLDING CELLS
FOR CHILDREN OR ARE BEING HELD
BECAUSE- COUNTIES EVEN WITH.
INTERCOUNTY AGREEMENTS CAN'T
SEEM TO FIND THE PLACEMENT
NECESSARY OR THEY JUST DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES FOR THE
RECORD THE FAMILIES OF. THE
PROFESSIONAL FAMILIES
AVAILABLE. SO I DO SEE THE
INTENT PYRRHUS- EXCELLENT
ACTUALLY IN. THE FACILITY
SUPPORTING THE BILL THINK
MANAGER. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
CORRECT THANK YOU- SENATOR
SKINNER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT YOU- DID OVER THE
BREAK WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
THE ADVOCATES YOU KNOW I WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
SHARED BY MY COLLEAGUES A
CRIMINAL RECORD DOES NOT
NECESSARILY PREDICATED ON SAFE
CONDITIONS- OR EVEN THAT IT IS
AND SAFE IN SOMEONE'S HOME WHEN
I WOULD ACTUALLY ARGUE THAT ONE
OF THE GREATEST CHALLENGES THE
FAMILY SUCCESS IS BREAKING
FAMILIES UP- AND AS OFTEN AS WE
ARE IN PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
AND OTHER COMMITTEES LISTENING
TO THE STORIES MOSTLY TOLD BY-
BLACKENED BROWN FATHERS. WHO
ARE SEPARATED FROM THEIR
CHILDREN- BECAUSE OF PAST
BEHAVIOR- IS ONE OF THE MOST.
EGREGIOUS I THINK IN TELLING
SIGNS OF AN INABILITY FOR
FAMILIES TO HEAL- IN CHILDREN
TO HAVE A REAL UNDERSTANDING OF
WHO THEIR PARENTS ARE. AND WE
HAVE REALLY DONE A DISSERVICE.
TO OUR FATHERS. IN THIS CYCLE
OF POVERTY AND FEAR. AND IN
DOING SO WE HAVE UNDERSCORED
THIS FALSEHOOD THAT THEY ARE
IRREDEEMABLE. THEY ARE SO BAD
THAT THEY DON'T EVEN DESERVE TO
HAVE- ACCESS TO THEIR CHILDREN
TO HAVE THEM PLACED IN THEIR
HOME OR IN THE HOME OF ONE OF
THEIR RELATIVES- AND WE HAVE
GOT TO MOVE FORWARD AND
DISMANTLE- THOSE KINDS OF
FALSEHOODS IN MISPERCEPTIONS SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK
IT IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR HOW WE ALLOW OUR
FAMILIES TO HEAL. AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK YOU-
TENER SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
CARE AND APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
A COMMENT SANDRA YES IT DOES
THE BILL WAS IMPROVED. AND I
THINK WHICH- ONE IT SQUARELY
PUTS THE SAFETY OF THE CHILD
FIRST IT EXEMPTS A NUMBER OF
CONVICTIONS A GOOD DEAL OF THEM.
AND IT PUTS IT- STREAM OR DID
STREAMLINED NOT THE RIGHT WORD
HE CLARIFIES THE PROCESS THAT
HAS TO BE GONE THROUGH FOR. THE
ROSS'S FOR DETERMINING WHETHER
THE PAST CONVICTION SHOULD BE
APPLIED OR NOT. NOW ONE THING I
WOULD RAISE SNOWED IN THE BILL
AT THE MOMENT BUT- AT SOME
POINT IN THE FUTURE WE MAY WANT
TO LOOK AT THAT LIST OF PAST
CONVICTIONS BECAUSE IF YOU SEE
IT LOOK AT IT IS QUITE
EXTENSIVE. AND WE ARE MAKING
CHANGES NOW TO SENTENCING THAT
CLARIFY DIFFERENT CRIMES WE'VE%
HAD IN MANY CASES IN CALIFORNIA
AN OVERLY BROAD. SET OF IN THE
PENAL CODE SAID OF SENSING SO
IF I TAKE FELONY MURDER FOR
EXAMPLE. FELONY MURDER IMPLIES
THAT YOU MURDERED WE HAVE- THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR WE
REVISE THAT LAW SO THAT. IN
ORDER TO BE CONVICTED OF FELONY
MURDER. YOU ACTUALLY HAD TO
HAVE A VERY SPECIFIC ROLE OR
INTENT TO KILL IT. HOWEVER
THERE WERE MANY PEOPLE
CONVICTED OF FELONY MURDER
WITHOUT THAT MANY OF THEM NOW
HAVE BEEN RESENTENCED. HAVING
BEEN RESENTENCED THOUGH YOU
STILL HAD THAT ORIGINAL
CONVICTION. SO HOPEFULLY THIS
BILL WOULD NOT. ELIMINATE THE
ABILITY OF A PERSON WHO IS
RESENTENCED FOR EXAMPLE FROM
BEING ABLE TO BE A CARE GIVER
IF THEY'RE IN THE SITUATION
EITHER YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO
TRY TO GET THEIR CHILD BACK
WERE IF THEY WERE IN A
SITUATION WHERE ANOTHER FAMILY
MEMBER. WAS WHATEVER A CHILD
WAS REMOVED FROM THAT FAMILY
MEMBER AND YOU WERE TRYING TO
FIND A RELATIVE TO PUT THE
CHILD IN THE PLACE- I DID NOT
GO INTO THE DETAIL TO DETERMINE
FOR EXAMPLE. IF THE BILL IS
WRITTEN IN SUCH A WAY. TO HELP
INSURE THAT BUT I RECENT ONLY
BECAUSE- WHILE IT IS LEGITIMATE
FOR US TO BE CAUTIOUS AND
LEGITIMATE FOR US ALWAYS TO
MAKE THE CHILDREN SAFETY FIRST.
USING A LIST OF PAST CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS DOES NOT
NECESSARILY INFORM US. IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE CHILD
SAFETY. SO I JUST RAISE IT AS
FOOD FOR THOUGHT AS WE MOVE ON
AND FUTURE. I THINK THE BILL IS
IN GOOD SHAPE NOW AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE. ALL OF YOUR
SUPPORT. AND THE WORK THAT WAS
DONE ON IT. AND I THINK IT
WILL- GREATLY HELP US WE HAVE
SO MANY CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE'VE HAD
DIFFICULTY GETTING PLACEMENT
FOR THEM SO IF THIS IMPROVES
THAT. THEN IT'S A GREAT STEP
FORWARD. BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS TYPE OF QUESTION AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU WITH
THAT I ESCRIBO. THANK YOU
CENTERS FOR DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. ON SENATOR PAN WE HAVE
A MOTION. EXECUTOR CAN PLEASE
MAKE CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SB THREE FIVE FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. HER TADO ABILITY.
JONES JONES BY CORTEZ C. CORTEZ
THE I. COM MARKER AND CAMARGO
AYE PAN RIGHT HAND BY. THE BILL
IS FOUR ZERO NINE BILLS OUT
THANK THE CENTER SKINNER AND WE
HAVE ONE MORE BILL THAT IS ON
CALL AND THAT IS IT AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. B. TWO COURSES
PLUS OUR LABOR. AND CAN WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THAT.
SB TWO FOUR SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION COM WALKER
ABSOLUTELY. COM LONGER I'D YEAH.
OKAY THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO ON
THE BILL AND THAT BILL IS OUT I
WANT TO THANK ALL BE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU.
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA. THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE IS
KNOWLEDGEABLE.